foreign
thank you
oh I had that on thank you very much
um good afternoon our business today is
to consider two items the first I'll
discuss is hr2 the secure the Border Act
of 2023 situation in our Southern border
can be described with one word chaos
it's a national security and
humanitarian crisis of unprecedented
proportions the present State of Affairs
cannot stand for more than two years
we've watched as operational control of
our border has been lost to Reckless
policy decisions the Democrats open
border agenda started with halting the
border wall construction that was
followed by the reinstatement of Catch
and Release termination of remain in
Mexico and measures that tied the hands
of law enforcement under President Biden
we've experienced some of the largest
waves of illegal border crossings in
recorded history exceeding 1.7 million
in 2021 2.3 million in 2022 and 1.2
million so far in 2023 according to the
cbp's own numbers these numbers only
scratched the surface of the Grim
realities that we Face a porous border
is anything but kind or compassionate it
has empowered drug cartels and human
traffickers it's allowed Fentanyl and
illicit drugs to flow into our
communities and it's become a path
utilized by Terror suspects to try and
sneak into our homeland this broken
system is endangering lives and U.S
security enough is enough it's time for
Congress to act and begin to repair the
Damage Done by the radical posturing and
inaction of the Biden Administration
unlike the previous majority House
Republicans are committed to
prioritizing the needs of the American
people over the wish list of extreme
Open Door activists In This Very Room
over the past four years House
Republicans pleaded with the
administration and house Democrats to
finally acknowledge the humanitarian and
security crisis at the border time and
again they denied or downplayed it the
facts speak for themselves the tragedy
and horror are too significant for even
open border Advocates to dismiss
today House Republicans are taking
action to secure our border and stop the
surge of illegal immigration through
consideration of hr2 to secure the
Border Act of 2023 this bill is a
complete rejection of President Biden's
border policies and purposeful inaction
it includes important reforms to combat
Fraud and Abuse in the Asylum process
prevents the catch and release of aliens
into the into American communities and
establishes new penalties for Visa
overstays hr2 also provides the
resources and Direction necessary to
secure the Border once and for all it
immediately resumes construction to the
border wall which President Biden
unilaterally halted on his first day in
office and adds more physical barriers
and tactical infrastructure along the
border importantly this bill gives our
dedicated border patrol agents the
resources equipment and manpower to meet
their mission and gain operational
control
together these measures will go a long
way to secure our Southern border and
end the reign of terror that cartels are
perpetrating against vulnerable
populations
we have a constitutional obligation to
secure our border and keep Americans
safe hr2 will help us uphold that
commitment our second measure for today
is H.R 1163 they're protecting taxpayers
and victims of unemployment fraud act at
the beginning of the covid-19 pandemic
Congress passed our acted to expand
unemployment insurance benefits to
ensure that millions of Americans who
were suddenly thrown out of work over
furloughed could continue to support
themselves
872 eight excuse me 878 billion dollars
both federal and state was spent on
unemployment benefits during the
pandemic unfortunately we're spending
that large fraud inevitably followed
while it is unclear how much of that 872
billion dollars was fraudulently paid
out estimates range from as low as 60
billion dollars to as high as 400
billion dollars H.R 1163 will allow
state to recover fraudulent overpayments
of federal and state pandemic
unemployment compensation and as an
incentive allow states to keep 25
percent of what they recover it's
essential that Congress takes steps to
ensure that fraudulent overpayments are
recovered hard-working American
taxpayers expect that the government
will be good stewards of every tax
dollar and those who have fraudulently
obtained funds from the unemployment
insurance program through criminal
activity must not profit from their bad
Deeds one final point
I know my friends on the other side of
the aisle have expressed concerns that
H.R 1163 will lead to a wave of States
going after otherwise innocent
individuals who inadvertently received
more than they should states have the
ability to use case-by-case individual
waivers to Grant relief to innocent
individuals who may have accidentally
received more than they should have for
this exact reason what we are concerned
with today is fraud and with targeting
those specific Bad actors who have
damaged the program Integrity of the
unemployment insurance system it's those
criminals and fraudsters at whom H.R
1163 is aimed I now yield to my good
friend our distinguished ranking member
Mr McGovern for any remarks he wishes to
make well thank you Mr chairman um
eight more innocent lives were lost
Saturday during a mass shooting this
time at a mall in Allen Texas
and while my heart goes out to the Allen
community and the victims families I'm
sickened that always seem capable of
doing is offering our thoughts and
prayers uh and nothing else
when will things get bad enough that we
will do something to keep our children
from being shot at school at grocery
stores at parades at movie theaters at
malls is beyond time that we take action
to protect Americans from gun violence
and I just I say that because I plead
with the majority to allow us to bring
measures to the floor so we can debate
and we can vote on ways to protect our
kids and innocent people uh and um
anyway that said today we are here to
consider two measures first is hr2 what
might as well be called the child
deportation Act
frankly this is the worst immigration
and border security Bill introduced in
my lifetime
Republicans would rather resort to more
fear-mongering more conspiracy theories
more political stunts and offer real
solutions to fix our broken immigration
system
we will get into we will get into
greater detail about all of hr2's
troubling Provisions later but let me
highlight a few for now
first this bill demonizes Asylum Seekers
looking to enter the country legally
these folks are fleeing their homes
everything they know because of a
well-founded fear of persecution they
are traveling thousands of miles often
on foot
they are looking to legally declare
Asylum under U.S law they have a legal
right to do that
this bill destroys the basic tenets of
our nation's Asylum system preventing
Customs and Border Protection from
Fairly and efficiently processing Asylum
Seekers and causing more chaos at the
border
Partnerships between the federal
government and nonprofits are essential
to meet the basic human needs of
migrants this bill discourages the
critical work of these humanitarian
organizations that help provide food
clothes and shelter to family seeking
Asylum
maybe my spiritual friends across the
aisle need to be reminded
and I quote I was hungry and you gave me
food I was thirsty and you gave me drink
I was a stranger and you welcomed me
Matthew chapter 25 verse 35.
keeping assistance from innocent people
seeking Refuge is immoral and absolutely
cruel hr2 also strips protections for
unaccompanied minors who arrive at the
border now we're talking about allowing
kids to be detained for a month or more
limiting their access to council and
sending them right back into the hands
of Smugglers that will exploit them this
is unconscionable
second this bill does nothing and I mean
nothing to prevent more drugs from
entering the country ninety percent of
all drug seizures occur at our points
points of Entry cartels aren't smuggling
drugs in on Mothers and children
arriving at our border on foot seeking
Asylum they are smuggling drugs in at
our airports and in cars and in trucks
at legal points of Entry
you would think that if Republicans were
interested in really tackling the drug
crisis they would enhance cbp's ability
to seize drugs at these points of Entry
right wrong
their debt limit bill would cut cbp's
budget by four billion dollars weakening
their ability to prevent drugs from
crossing the border by laying off 2 400
officers
if the gop's debt limit plan is enacted
estimates suggest that more than 350 000
grams of fentanyl could be led into the
country that's over 200 million more
fatal doses of fentanyl hitting our
streets thanks to Republicans funding
cuts
but they want to go after moms and kids
declaring Asylum
do you know what hr2 does fund it funds
Trump's border wall
as I say time and time again show me a
30-foot wall and I'll show you a 35-foot
ladder
third this bill will wreak absolute
havoc on our economy hr2 imposes
Nationwide e-verify on all U.S
businesses doing Untold damage to the
economy and resulting in billions of
dollars in Lost Revenue this bill could
wipe out half of our nation's
agricultural Workforce
I have farms in my district as I'm sure
many of you here do too let me be clear
American Farms will go under if this
bill becomes law
and the price of food in our grocery
stores and on our shelves will Skyrocket
even more
we all know that our immigration system
needs reform but this bill is not it hr2
is inhumane it is Un-American it does
nothing to prevent the very real issue
of drug smuggling and will do a
irreparable damage to our economy we
also have HR 1163 hosts Republicans
unemployment insurance so-called
anti-fraud Bill like hr2 this bill would
do more harm than good it advocates for
a surprise billing for workers who did
nothing wrong while slashing funding
from programs that hold actual scammers
accountable so I'm sure today I'm sure
today's meeting will be another lengthy
one I'm reading on social media that the
Republicans are scrambling for votes on
their immigration bills so God knows
when we'll report it out of this the
rules committee but in any event Mr
chairman I will at this point yield back
my time thank you very much without
objection any prepared statements that
our Witnesses may have will be included
in the record I'd like to welcome our
first panel chairman Jordan and ranking
member Nadler from the Judiciary
Committee chairman Greene and
representative Ivy from the homeland
security committee and chairman McCall
and representative Castro from the
Foreign Affairs committee chairman
Jordan I welcome you back to the rules
committee and I welcome your testimony
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
ranking member uh good to be with you
and committee members President Biden
and vice president Harris secretary
mayorkas all
and the vast majority of Democrats in
Congress keep telling us there is no
border crisis but numbers don't lie and
I know we get tired of hearing the
numbers but they do not lie since
President Biden took office there have
been
over five men illegal border crossers
encountered by U.S Customs and Border
Protection along the Southwest border 5
million over 1.5 million illegal alien
gotaways who successfully evaded capture
in the 28 months that Joe Biden's been
president and nearly 2 million other
illegal aliens released into the United
States over 370 000 unaccompanied Alien
Children
children encountered on our Southwest
border in place with health and human
services and at least and this is this
is unbelievable and frankly in response
to the ranking members Commons at least
85 000 of those kids have been lost by
the white Administration we don't know
where they're at we don't know what bad
things may be happening to kids nearly
200 alien terrorists encountered by the
border patrol along the Southwest border
and as we sit here today the surges
surrounding the end of title 42 have
already started we've all seen it border
patrol Chief Ortiz reported that his
agents encountered over 20 think about
this 26 000 aliens illegally crossing
the border
in 72 hours this past weekend just over
this past weekend a 72-hour time frame
last week where there were 55 000
illegal alien encounters
nearly 8 000 a day and there is no end
in sight in fact I would argue after
Thursday it will only get worse
according to the border patrol
intelligence sources around 700 000
migrants are waiting in Mexican shelters
to come to the United States when Title
II title 42 expires in two days they
will overrun our border patrol agents
they will overwhelm our resources and
they will overload our cities by some
estimates for supanama's Darian Gap
making their way up to our border this
year all because President Biden has
effectively invited them in this week
House Republicans will pass hr2 the
secure border act and make good on our
promise to pass legislation to secure
the border and protect our sovereignty
the Judiciary committee's provisions of
hr2 stopped the incentives to come to
the United States
Title One of division B reforms the
Asylum system to stop Asylum Fraud and
Abuse and and to ensure that valid
Asylum claims are heard expeditiously
specifically the bill includes bars to
criminals applying for Asylum requires
that the alien claim fear at a Port of
Entry increases the credible fear
standard Reigns in Immigration and
federal courts abuse of Asylum grounds
like particular social group
Title II ends the Biden Administration
Catch and Release policies clarifies
that the DHS secretary must remove or
detain illegal aliens who arrive at the
border or place them into a remain in
Mexico type program this is the heart of
the legislation I just want to be clear
Mr chairman people can come to Ports of
Entry claim Asylum God bless them for
doing if it's legit we're going to let
them in we want that adjudication to
half as quick happen as quick as
possible but we're not just going to
release them into the country they will
be detained or they will have to wait in
Mexico while we evaluate their claim
that is the most important thing I think
in the legislation there are no other
options the aliens cannot be paroled or
otherwise released in the United States
as I just said unless an Immigration
Court grants to alien Asylum or some
other immigration benefit
it also allows the DHS DHS secretary to
suspend entry of valence at the border
to gain operational control title IV
closes the Flores settlement agreement
loophole that has for many years
encourage families to cross the border
illegally it ensures that all aliens
will be detained for the dependency of
their Immigration Court proceedings and
kept together as a family the number of
real and fake family units crossing the
border has skyrocketed over the last
decade because aliens know that if they
have a child with them they will be they
will be released once they get to the
United States title V helps end the mass
exploitation and migration of
unaccompanied Alien Children it requires
that current law regarding unaccompanied
Alien Children from Mexico and Canada be
applied to children from other countries
this means that uacs kids from
non-contiguous countries will be
screened for trafficking this is
important or for a fear of return and if
none is found they will be sent home
reunited with their family in their home
country
we've all heard of the horror stories of
what these uacs go through during their
trip to the United States with Smugglers
we all know how they can be exploited
once here the bite Administration as I
said earlier cannot locate at least 85
000 of the 370 000 unaccompanied alien
children who have entered this United
States since Joe Biden took office in
2014 the Obama Administration asked
Congress to pass a law to give the
administration the ability to remove
uacs what we're doing in this bill the
bottom Administration asked for that in
response to house passed the language
that is in currently in this bill
unfortunately the Senate did not take up
that bill and the UAC surges have
continued I think I think this element
is critical to dealing with these these
kids and our our ranking member Mr
chairman talks about when a kid a kid
winds up on your doorstep you're going
to first you're gonna do is figure out
where those kids parents are get that
child back with their mom and dad that's
what our legislation seeks to do title
six puts Visa overstay on par with
illegal entry as a misdemeanor crime it
is currently just a civil immigration
diffraction title seven will help in the
abuse of immigration parole since
President Biden took office as part of
the Catch and Release he has paroled in
around a million aliens who illegally
cross the border the parole statute is
very clear it is to be used on a
case-by-case basis and only
for significant public benefit or a
humanitarian purpose administrations
have been abusing Parole Authority for
many years despite Congress attempts to
Reign it in most recently the Biden
Administration has created categorical
parole programs for Nationals of several
countries to make the chaos at the
border less noticeable Title VII brings
the use of immigration parole back to
its intended purpose to allow a foreign
National to enter the U.S for an
emergency purpose for a short period of
time and finally Title VII helps end the
jobs magnet for illegal migration
it faces in the required use to be
verified to check the employment
eligibility of new hires over a period
of three years starting with the largest
employers and ending with agricultural
employers we have worked closely with
many of our folks from the big AG
districts on that language he verifies a
quick and efficient way to
electronically do what current Law
requires of employers to check the
employment eligibility of their new
hires the current system is subjective
and illegal aliens routinely fake
identity employment eligibility
documents to get jobs in the United
States title 8 also repeals two Biden
Administration regulations that make the
h2a agricultural guessworker program
burdensome for employees to use
hr2 will put an into it
um the open borders policy of Joe Biden
and with that Mr chairman I yield back
thank you very much ranking member
Natalie you're recognized for your
opening testimony thank you Mr chairman
Mr chairman members of the committee
today the majority has brought forward a
cruel extreme and unworkable piece of
legislation the so-called secure the
Border act which would wreck our economy
destroy the Asylum system criminalize
Visa overstays send unaccompanied
children back to dangerous situations
and to jail children indefinitely
once again my Republican colleague shows
that they are not interested in finding
real solutions to tough issues this bill
attempts to combine a variety of
different bills each one more cruel and
heartless than the last
into one contradictory and overlapping
mess
this bill has no chance of being enacted
into law Republican Senators have
expressed their opposition it is nothing
more than pure political theater
my Republican colleagues are trying to
take us back to the failed illegal and
immoral policies of the Trump
Administration
former president Trump's radical
inhumane and racist immigration actions
weakened the U.S economy undermined our
moral standing in the world and did not
make us any safer while trampling on
some of our most deeply held American
values his erratic approach also failed
to stem the flow of migrants across our
border
let's be very clear about what this
legislation would do
when taken together this bill serves as
a wholesale ban on Asylum no one would
be able to seek asylum in the United
States if they cross between points of
Entry or if they had or could have had
even temporary status in a third country
we offered a variety of amendments to
exempt the most vulnerable from some of
these Draconian requirements this
included those fleeing communist and
totalitarian regimes and unaccompanied
children
the majority was not even willing to
exempt children under a year old
the one place where we were where we
were able to make some bipartisan
Headway was on the issue of e-verify he
verifies an electronic employment
eligibility verification system that
began as a voluntary pilot program and
is currently used by a small percentage
of the nation's employers
this bill would make that system
mandatory for all Employers in the
United States
without providing other reforms
including any meaningful opportunity for
undocumented workers to regularize their
status this title would damage the US
economy harm American workers and result
in billions of dollars in Lost
government uh Revenue
mandatory e-verify would decimate the
agriculture industry putting U.S Farms
out of business shipping millions of
American jobs overseas and increasing
U.S Reliance on imported food
mandatory e-verify will result in
hundreds of thousands of unfilled farm
jobs and will leave unpicked crops
riding in the fields as we saw in
Georgia in 2011 when a mandatory
e-verify law in the state resulted in
over 11
000 farm jobs going unfilled during the
peak harvest season
that is why I have submitted an
amendment to the rules committee which
which would strike the e-verified title
from this bill
this amendment gained bipartisan support
in the Judiciary Committee and I hope my
colleagues will ensure it gets a vote on
the house floor
these are just a few of the problems
with this bill
I did not even have time to go into
detail into how this bill strips or
protections from unaccompanied children
and requires All Families to come to our
border seeking protection to be detained
indefinitely
or the extreme lens to which it goes to
narrow the eligibility grounds for
Asylum or how this bill would severely
restrict this and any future
administration's ability to parole
individuals into the United States
ending the current parole initiatives
for ukrainians fleeing Russia and
certain military families and I might
add ending the parole that has been
enforced for
Cuba since the Eisenhower Administration
immigration reform is a complicated
problem that requires comprehensive
Solutions and then enforcement only
strategy simply doesn't work
Democrats have put forward real
proposals and we stand ready to work
with serious Republicans to pass
meaningful Solutions
Democrats take this complex humanitarian
crisis seriously
our proposals address the root causes of
migration improve border security and
create additional legal Pathways for
people to enter the United States
lawfully
but Republicans have chosen a narrow
path that imposes extreme pain and
hardship on the most vulnerable people
while doing nothing to actually solve
the problem
I encourage my colleagues to oppose this
wrong-headed bill they ask the majority
to go back to the drawing board thank
you Mr chairman I yield back thank you
chairman Greene you're recognized for
your opening testimony German Cole
ranking member McGovern and members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify on hr2 to secure
the Border Act of 2023. there is now
absolutely no doubt to any American
paying attention that we're in the midst
of a severe border crisis
in just over two years President Biden
and secretary Marcus have turned the
border into a place of chaos and
Devastation a place where cartels are
now firmly in control of at least five
of our nine sectors according to the
chief of the Border Patrol
since the bite Administration took
office there have been over 5 million
encounters at the Southwest border 1.5
million known gotaways and estimates by
the chief of border patrol of an
additional 20 percent of gotaways that
are completely unaccounted for the
numbers paint a horrifying picture
but if you look deeper it gets worse in
just the first six months of this fiscal
year 80 people on the terrorist watch
list were stopped by trying to cross the
U.S Mexican border between ports of
Entry border patrol arrested over 15 000
individuals with criminal convictions
and 14 000 pounds of fentanyl has been
seized enough to kill over 3.1 billion
people a third of the world or the
entire U.S population nine times over
sadly the true number of cartel and gang
members other criminals and trafficked
persons as well as the quantity of
illicit drugs that have all crossed our
borders will never be fully known but
what we do know is staggering given
these facts it's imperative that
Congress take the necessary steps to
ensure that the laws passed by this body
are enforced
our borders are secure and the American
people are safe I'm honored to be here
with chairman Jordan and chairman McCall
as we work toward this goal to secure
the Border Act each of our committees
has worked tirelessly over the past
several months to craft this legislation
doing so through regular order the
committee on homeland Securities mark up
two weeks ago extended over 16 hours
considered over 40 amendments and I'm
grateful to the members of the committee
who work tirelessly to craft our part of
this bill hr2 addresses the immediate
impact of the crisis by focusing on
mitigating and stopping the surge of
illegal aliens and drugs flowing across
the U.S borders mainly between ports of
Entry this bill requires the Secretary
of Homeland Security to use previously
appropriated but unexpired funding to
immediately resume construction of the
border wall it also marks makes targeted
investment in Border technology by
deploying the most effective technology
available such as advanced surveillance
sensors and drones and requires a
five-year technology investment plan to
provide an analysis of security risks
and capability gaps at and between ports
of Entry
this bill also demands transparency from
DHS by requiring monthly reporting of
critical border security data including
the number of known gotaways and known
or suspected terrorists the American
people expect this type of transparency
it also authorizes and increases
operations Stone Garden Grants to
support state and local law enforcement
who are bearing the brunt of this crisis
as the federal government continues to
fail in its mission
lastly the bill addresses the major
Staffing challenges at U.S border Patrol
which was just recently highlighted in a
DHS Inspector General report laying out
how the unsustainable conditions at our
Southwest border are negatively
impacting the health and morale of the
front line law enforcement our brave
border patrol agents whose frustrations
grow daily as they are pulled off the
front line to act as processing
coordinators are leaving at an
increasing rate and are greatly
struggling with mental health issues to
address these issues this bill includes
retention bonuses for those Frontline
agents mandates no fewer than 22
thousand full-time equivalent agents and
also provides polygraph waiver Authority
for hiring flexibility there these are
just a few of the highlights of this
critical legislation we must have
effective physical infrastructure
additional border patrol agents on the
front lines to address these growing
threats combined with the important
elements led by the Judiciary and
Foreign Affairs committee this bill is a
major step in tackling these challenges
and delivering for the America people
left unaddressed the Border crisis will
continue to spiral out of control thank
you Mr chairman for the opportunity to
testify today I look forward to the
committee's questions and I yield back
thank you very much representative Ivy
you're recognized for your opening
statement thank you Mr chairman Mr
ranking member I'm here to express my
strong opposition to hr2 and urge the
committee to approve a rule to allow for
consideration of democratic amendments
aimed at addressing serious flaws in
this cruel and unworkable Bill although
I sit on the homeland security committee
and the Judiciary Committee I'm here to
speak on behalf of ranking member
Thompson about division a of hr2
the language in this division which was
voted out of the homeland security
committee about two weeks ago along
partisan's lines after a 7 17-hour
markup
reflects a failure of cooperation and
coordination between the two groups of
of members the Democrats and the
Republicans the majority rejected 43
Democratic amendments even when they
expressly recognize the Merit and some
of the Amendments that were offered by
the Democrats at the time
uh
if enacted hr2 would upend border
enforcement operations villainized
community and religious organizations
working to provide migrants with basic
necessities that's why 136 community and
religious organizations
oppose this legislation they have a
letter that I would like to submit to
make it part of the record
hr2 would require DHS to build Donald
Trump's border wall and vaguely points
to unspent border wall funds from the
Trump era as a pay for my Republican
colleagues identified no one spent funds
as mentioned in the bill that are
available to DHS to begin construction
on the wall and the legislation requires
them to Begin work on this in seven days
after enactment
uh moreover
roughly not 1 950 miles of additional
wall construction is estimated to be
required to complete the Republican
mandate I've seen estimates of that
costing roughly 46 million dollars per
mile so on the one hand we have no
funding that made available under the
legislation not not expressly at least
but an astronomical amount to actually
do what they're saying should be done in
addition to that
House Republicans just adopted a bill to
require 22 percent across the board cut
to DH DHS funding I think the ranking
member estimated that would be somewhere
around a reduction of 2400 border agents
at the same time my Republican
colleagues are saying oh and the Border
agents and officers themselves are
saying they need more help down at the
border
um
but the bill doesn't fund a single new
officer and a Port of Entry to bolster
fentanyl interdiction even though
successive administrations have
acknowledged that more than 90 percent
of this deadly drug come through ports
of Entry
last month I joined with committee
colleagues to visit with officers in
Brownsville point of entry in McAllen
Texas the men and women were serving at
the border are doing important work
under very difficult conditions
that led us ranking member Thompson in
particular to offer amendments to try
and address
additional funding for members of the uh
of the Border officers and agents to try
and raise the funding to have them get
additional payments I know there was a
language in there about adding for
bonuses this would actually Elevate
their overall pay on an ongoing basis
and allow them to to equalize with civil
service payment
in addition to that
um
uh we also offered a language that would
allow the officers and agents to
unionize so that they could protect
their benefits and we also offered
language that would I think it was
raised a moment ago about spiritual
issues and challenges that many of the
agents and officers are facing On the
Border we offered an amendment to expand
that to brought provide additional
counseling which was suggested by the
officers and agents we talked with down
at the border but that that amendment
was ejected as well
uh we debated a section that targets
non-profits that work with migrants and
other immigrants for hours but in the
end the Republicans retained language
that punishes these Community religious
and charitable organizations for
carrying out their missions of providing
life-saving services to those in need
specifically
section 115 would Place unworkable
requirements on DHS Partners including
those who don't operate at the border
the broadness of the provision would
mean that FEMA's disaster management
Partners would be required to verify
every individual's immigration status or
providing critical assistance like
shelter or transportation in addition to
that at the hearing
one of our members raised the issue of
the requirements that they would face in
trying to identify
the definition of aliens that was put
into a new amendment that was offered
the night of the markup which has never
been seen by any of the ngos or had any
chance to be vetted by anybody else and
it's pretty clear I think we've got a
letter that I just offered and we have
another one from uh Catholic Bishops in
El Paso and Texas that raised the same
concerns about this provision
uh this
uh and a member of uh in a letter to
members of Congress Bishop Mark Seitz
the bishop alprazo and chairman of the
U.S Conference of Catholic Bishops uh on
migration wrote quote as drafted these
Provisions give could even be
interpreted to prevent schools houses of
worship and other organizations from
qualifying for the non-profit security
grant program amid a rise in violent
attacks on those places the bishop
continued quote
dhs's ability to rescue persons
encountered in the desert in
life-threatening circumstances and
process unaccompanied children victims
of trafficking victims of torture and
others who even under this bill's own
terms would warrant such processing
would be compromised
Democrats tried to strike section 115
altogether but
committee Republicans refused to do so
alternatively we offered language that
would have created other exceptions to
this for Afghans who helped our military
personnel overseas for pregnant women
women who are survivors of human
trafficking or domestic violence or
sexual assault all of those amendments
were voted down we needed a we need an
open bill or an open rule to address the
very real problems with this bill that
we were not able to address at the
committee level
uh and with that I yield back
thank you very much representative
McCall you're recognized for your
opening statement famous chairman a
ranking member
um you know throughout my career as a
federal prosecutor in the state of Texas
uh chairman of the homeland security
committee now chairman of the Foreign
Affairs committee I've never seen this
board or more out of control
in my home state of Texas is taking the
brunt of this crisis in fact Chief
border patrol officer Ortiz testified
that we no longer have operational
control of the Border this didn't have
to happen
and I would argue it's a self-inflicted
womb
the reason for this chaos is a direct
result of the Biden administration's
termination on day one
of two the most effective policies
implemented during the previous
administration
and that is a migrant protection
protocols and Asylum Cooperative
agreements in fact don't take my word
for it the border patrol tells you
that's this
that the rescission of these policies on
day one had a direct cause and effect on
the chaos that we're now seeing
and these policies worked because they
required migrants to remain in Mexico
pending their Asylum claims instead of
being released into the United States
now we're back to the policy of catch
and release
it also prohibited migrants from
eligibility for U.S Asylum if they pass
through any countries with these Asylum
agreements
but since the bite Administration took
office migrant counters have soared to 5
million
fentanyl's flowing across the border has
killed over a hundred thousand Americans
many of them young people my son just
went to a funeral one of his best
friends last week and my daughter's been
to four
my committee's contribution to the House
GOP border package will reinstate and
codify the migrant protection protocols
known as remain in Mexico
and it will also direct the Secretary of
State to re-enter MPP and acas to bring
back order to our immigration system and
protect Americans
for without acting we were silently
enabling the human Smugglers sex
traffickers and drug cartels
all while leaving our border Patrol's
agent agents at continued risk by the
way the suicide rates never been higher
than it is today
this should not be a partisan issue to
give our government the tools they need
to stem this generational crisis and
restore U.S operation control to the
border and I want to commend chairman
Jordan
chairman Green for their hard work on
this
this would be the strongest border
security bill ever passed by
the United States House of
Representatives if we pass this on
Thursday which by the way title 42 will
be revoked on Thursday
no doubt the flood at the border will
only get worse not better with that
yield back thank you very much
representative Castro your recognized
for your opening statement uh thank you
chairman Cole ranking member McGovern
and members of the rules committee and
thank you for the opportunity to testify
in opposition specifically to Title II
of hr2 title III I'm sorry hr2 which was
marked up in the house Foreign Affairs
committee as H.R 1690 the order act I'm
glad to join you in my capacity as
ranking member of the House Foreign
Affairs committee subcommittee on the
Western Hemisphere
last year marked a hundred years since
my grandmother Victoria Castro came to
the United States as a young orphan in
the wake of the Mexican Revolution
on her paperwork the San Antonio
relatives who took her in wrote that she
was coming to live
in America she found a better life just
as many of your ancestors did the Irish
the Germans the English the Spanish
immigrants with descendants in this room
today
and today we Face different challenges
with migration and I don't think there's
a single person in this room who
believes that our current immigration
system meets our country's needs
but instead of tackling these challenges
head on title III of this bill would
Institute destructive dangerous policies
that Force vulnerable Asylum Seekers
into even more desperate circumstances
when similar protocols were previously
in place human rights observers recorded
thousands of violent attacks against
migrants sent to Mexico including
kidnapping rape and other very brutal
crimes
that so-called remain in Mexico policy
as cruel as it was included exemptions
for unaccompanied minors children and
people who don't speak Spanish this bill
includes neither of those exemptions
if hr2 becomes law Asylum Seekers from
across the world would be required to
First apply for asylum in Mexico
Guatemala Honduras or El Salvador
countries that combined have less than
one twentieth of the U.S GDP
and let's be honest many people in this
room won't even drink the water when
they go to these countries
some advocates for the bill have
described this as quote burden sharing
but the country's named in this bill
cannot shoulder the same burden as the
world's largest economy our nation nor
should they be expected to
when we talk about immigration policy I
think folks often lose sight of the real
people that our discussions affect
last month in the house Foreign Affairs
committee I introduced an amendment to
exempt people with disabilities
persecuted religious minorities and even
Ukrainian refugees from this bill
but every single member of the
Republican majority voted it down
under hr2 as drafted for example if a
uyghur Muslim escapes one of China's
concentration camps in xinjiang and
makes it to Mexico and seeks asylum in
the United States the United States
would force that person to remain in
Mexico
if a group of Cuban dissidents sail to
Florida and land outside of a Port of
Entry they would not be allowed to apply
for Asylum
under this bill ukrainians fleeing
Russia's brutal invasion of their
Homeland Catholics fleeing religious
persecution in Nicaragua and Christians
or other religious minorities fling Iran
would all be required to remain in
Mexico Guatemala Honduras or El Salvador
rather than Unite with family right here
in the United States
many of my colleagues on both sides of
the aisle have expressed concerns about
how our immigration system will be able
to handle a rising tide and the rising
number of immigrants post title 42 and I
agree that we need to build a more
resilient and more efficient and
effective system
but what we've seen time and time again
is that cruel restrictive policies like
title 42 and remain in Mexico do not
stop desperate people from fleeing
persecution oppression and violence
this bill sadly is a way
to get rid of a problem without solving
it
and that's the best that we could hope
to accomplish by passing this piece of
legislation
instead it forces vulnerable people to
take dangerous irregular paths to the
United States the exact kind of Journey
that led to the deaths of 53 people in
the back of a sweltering tractor-trailer
in my hometown of San Antonio Last
Summer
hr2 also ends humanitarian parole except
in very limited circumstances
since the February 20 2022 in Russian
invasion of Ukraine the United States
for example has admitted a hundred and
fifty thousand ukrainians and their
family members on humanitarian parole
if we pass hr2 these families fleeing
Putin's Invasion would lose the ability
to be in the United States
let me say that again they would lose
the ability to be in the United States
the Afghans who fought alongside the
United States and were evacuated from
Kabul in August 2021 are largely in the
United States through humanitarian
parole
if we pass hr2 they would lose the
ability to remain in the United States
in February of this year the United
States evacuated 222 Brave nicaraguans
who were imprisoned by the Ortega
muriombu regime they are here with their
families on parole and two of these
individuals testify to the house Foreign
Affairs Committee in March they too
would lose their status
Mr chairman there are meaningful
bipartisan solutions to address the
causes of forced migration to the United
States and I've been proud to work
across the aisle to introduce several
bills that would expand the scope of U.S
foreign assistance to encourage
sustainable economic development in many
of these countries that we're talking
about today
unfortunately hr2 does not include any
serious attempt to address the root
causes of migration and so people will
keep coming
this bill is harmful and
counterproductive and it betrays our
nation's legal and moral obligations to
assign The Seekers who deserve better
and also betrays America's Legacy
before I yield
I want to make a brief point about the
rhetoric used
during this debate in this Congress and
also in this country
in 2019 a Madman in my home state of
Texas
drove 10 hours to El Paso Texas and
murdered 23 people including American
citizens
to stop what he called the Hispanic
quote invasion
when members of Congress use their
elevated platforms to dehumanize
migrants and fear Monger about quote
unquote illegals aliens and invasions
their words have consequences that Echo
far beyond these Halls
the language that we use matters
and I urge members of this committee and
of this Congress to be mindful about how
your rhetoric can put a Target on the
backs of migrants and those who may
Target them
thank you for the opportunity to speak
on this bill I yield back thank you very
much I just have a few questions and I'm
going to direct my direct them to the
three chairmen we're privileged to have
with us today so chairman Jordan green
will call I understand that you've all
your respective committees have held
hearings highlighting the causes of this
unprecedented illegal immigration surge
on our Southern border and the effects
that having on Border residents border
communities throughout the country
can you tell us a few of the real life
consequences your Witnesses have
described and I'll start with you
chairman Jordan oh thank you Mr chairman
um so I think all the Committees have
had parents who lost a loved one lost
son or daughter to uh fentanyl so those
those always sink in is you know that's
powerful testimony from a mom or a dad
but I think for me also was it was when
we did the field Hearing in Yuma uh
hearing from the hospital administrator
what it's meant to the hospital there
and then hearing from the farmers
um I mean they've had to verify in their
state it works fine they they love that
that that what they have in in Arizona
and yet they talked about the damage
done because of the flood of of illegal
migrants coming in the country uh what
it's done to their fields people just
camping out in their fields so I think
there's real consequences for the people
who produce our food I learned an
interesting fact when we were in Yuma
they said 90 of the leafy green
vegetables we eat during the winter come
from Yuma Arizona I had no idea when we
that was one of the facts we learned
when we're down there so but the most
powerful ones are always the moms and
dads talking about what fentanyl did to
a loved one and their family thank you
very much chairman green same question
to you can you tell us a little bit
about what the witnesses appeared before
your committee had to tell you about the
consequences of the surge we're dealing
with thank you Mr chairman you know
there there are the human costs and then
there are the physical the financial
costs of this uh open border and of
course chairman Jordan mentioned a few
of the human costs fentanyl you know
taking that a step further uh Tennessee
is faced with having to take care of
children that are born to fentanyl
addicted mothers
that is a human tragedy because a child
is born addicted to an opiate that child
winds up in the ICU
Etc
there are learning disabilities that are
associated with that addiction from
birth
so there is the human side of it but
there's also the financial side of it it
costs the state of Tennessee a million
six hundred thousand dollars per child
and we had forty thousand of those last
year
so if you sit and think about the human
costs and then you think of all of the
various Financial costs of this it is
substantial and the the CEO
that chairman Jordan mentions also came
and testified about his uncompensated
health care costs
the fact that the human side of that is
people from his own Community have to go
200 miles to deliver babies because his
his uh obstetrics award is full of of
migrants
um and I know it's been implied earlier
that that this bill somehow stops people
from getting Health Care it does not we
have an imtala law in this country that
every every patient who presents himself
will be taken care of we're not undoing
imtala in this in this legislation so
that's uh that's misin information but
there is a human cost it's absolute
suffering uh the magnet that brings them
in was a change in policy and political
Asylum because the cartels are really
smart they know that our laws changed on
day one they can now get these
these people inside the United States
and then they make this dangerous
Journey
I've seen horrific filmage of the what
the cartels do without getting into
graphic detail but then once they get
into the United States Mr chairman what
are we going to do with 5 million people
that have no legal status in this
country that have to live in the shadows
where do the young women go
they get sex trafficking where do the
young men go they go to MS-13 or gangs
they become their families
there are stash houses inside the United
States where 20 of these adopted
children or sponsored children go to
that makes no sense at all because
they're being trafficked in the United
States
to make things worse I've seen 18
wheelers stuffed with bodies that have
have died in Mr Castro's District
that have been smuggled into the United
States and they have suffocated and died
because the Smugglers don't give a damn
about them they just care about the
money
and that's what's driving this it's a
change in policy and I do have to
respond I do respect my dear friend from
San Antonio Mr Castro however this will
our my bill will have no impact on
someone's ability to apply for political
Asylum that Still Remains their right
and in fact he talks a lot about
ukrainians in Afghanistan who I have
done a lot to protect they are the ones
already in the United States are
protected
and individuals already paroled in the
United States are protected and our bill
clearly says that so I do want to
correct the record on that but the human
suffering uh Mr chairman and thanks for
the question
um it's it's it's horrific and it needs
to stop
thank you very much once again to our
three chairmen along the same lines
could each of you talk briefly and walk
us through the committee markups that
resulted in the bill that we're
considering today talk about the process
that got you to your product so to speak
and again I'll start with you chairman
Jordan
uh thank you Mr chairman it was a long
process uh with lots of amendments
offered
um some some things we had to work with
our own members on on uh some clarifying
language that has been not only done in
the committee but also in in conjunction
with uh members not on the Judiciary
Committee and we've worked closely and I
want to come into other the other
committees as well work closely with Mr
Green and Mr McCall so it was a long
process but we pushed through it and I
think you said this in your opening
statement I appreciate it I do think
it's the strongest immigration
enforcement legislation that we've ever
put together and I hope in fact it
passes on Thursday which I think it will
thank you very much chairman green same
question talk to us a little bit about
the process that got you to the your
portion of the bill thank you chairman
Cole we uh as soon as I got the
opportunity to lead the committee I
began meeting with the members and
really folks across the entire
conference and assembled the ideas put
the language together uh rebuilt that
language a couple of different times the
actual markup itself was as I mentioned
earlier 16 hours it was lengthy we had a
lot of amendments brought forward I will
say that to Mr Ivey's Point earlier some
of those Amendments have some hope but
they need work and we intend to work
with the our colleagues across the aisle
to develop some of those ideas and and
and we will have a bipartisan uh hearing
to address those issues that were
brought up
um but they did they weren't in uh in a
place where we could put them on this
bill and it didn't fit this bill so
um a lot of hard work a lot of Labor a
lot of uh cooperation and uh I think the
product that we got is a good one and I
agree with Mr Jordan uh you know our our
dialogue across committees between
committees has been fantastic and I
appreciate his leadership and insight
and mentorship thank you very much and
again Mr McCall do you same thing can
you tell us a little bit about the
process that you went through to get to
your portion of the bill sure we we've
had several hearings on this issue uh we
had contact with many organizations on
the outside many groups you know about
this we had a full day of markup
um
you know I've even uh I have to say Mr
chairman I've you know as I mentioned my
opening statement I've gone down to the
Border many times I've talked to the
chief border patrol officers down there
about what caused this phenomenon
and I'm trying to make this as objective
as I can they're not Republican or
Democrat down there they say the direct
cause and effect was a rescission of the
migrant protection protocols remained in
Mexico
I don't think there's any dispute about
that even the cheap border patrol
officer even Secretary of my orcas knows
better and I've had conversations with
him as well as a Secretary of State
blinken who knows that when we have
these policies in place that take the
magnet away
that this policy does work I think
because it was enacted under the
previous administration and it had
Trump's name attached to it they didn't
want to touch it
and it's a political move
and it's a bad policy
thank you very much before we proceed to
the next member for questions I
understand I'm advised that we need to
switch one of our witnesses to any
members have any questions specifically
for Mr Ivory before we do that
he may not be good Mr rank remember so I
want to give him that option so seeing
none without objection
ranking member Thompson will replace Mr
Ivey on the panel
it was a good move by Mr Ivory
without go to our distinguished ranking
member Mr McGovern for any questions he
cares to offer well thank you Mr
chairman I won't take very much time I
just um you know as I said during my
opening um I I think this is an awful
bill
um that is just page after page of
empty talking points with no real
solutions
um you know instead of actually solving
problems this bill actually creates
problems I think it it it it does it
eviscerates our Asylum process and with
respect to Chairman McCall
um the Asylum part of this bill
comes out of the Judiciary Committee
um and I don't know whether Mr Castro
wants to address that it's it's I just I
want direct to be clear what we're
talking about here what's in this bill
sure uh thank you ranking member and
like I know how much hard work uh
chairman McCall has done for example on
getting Afghans you know
families that had relatives over there
and helping evacuate them and being
serious about policy and so forth but
this is this bill was in several titles
and was the work of three committees so
when I was referring to the bill I was
referring specifically to the fact that
title II limits Asylum and Title VII
limits parole uh both outside of what we
did in foreign affairs so that is
something that has to be resolved I
think with this piece of legislation
because perhaps there is some internal
conflict among those titles
thank you and you know and you know and
and as I said before this bill won't
stop drugs from getting into uh America
because drugs like fentanyl are coming
through legal points of Entry uh not via
a migrant uh seeking migrants seeking
Asylum and again I just I can't resist
uh from pointing out that uh in the debt
ceiling bill that uh my friends all
voted for a couple of weeks ago um it
would cut the cbp's budget by four
billion dollars
you know I mean weakening the ability to
prevent drugs from crossing the border
uh by laying off 2 400 officers I mean I
uh you know and uh you know if if this
plan were enacted there were estimates
that more than 350 000 grams of fentanyl
could be led into this country that's
over 200 million more fatal doses of
fentanyl hitting our street streets uh
thanks to these cuts that my friends
voted for if in fact they moved forward
um half or more of the undocumented
people uh are overstaying their visas
not Crossing at the southern border
and some to try to score political
points which I hear over and over and
over again in some of the testimony here
today by demonizing immigrants and I
want to emphasize the point that Mr
Castro made that language has
consequences
and we see the impact of that language
and those consequences every every day
and it's quite frankly tragic and it has
to stop but let me just get into just a
couple of things that
you know during the markup of the bill
Democrats introduced an amendment
allowing for ukrainians to continue to
be paroled into the United States until
it is safe for them to go back I mean
that's all it said
um so if you're from Ukraine and your
home has been destroyed thanks to
Putin's war of aggression you can stay
until it's safe for you to go back
the Biden Administration started a youth
for you program that helped save
Ukrainian lives and it seems to me my
Republican friends want to undo this
program so we gave Republicans an
opportunity to correct the mistake to
allow the administration to continue
using parole for ukrainians who are
fleeing Putin's war crimes and
Republicans voted no
they voted to send them back into Harm's
Way and by the way ukrainians don't
qualify for Asylum because the
restrictions are so narrow
so Mr Jordan let me let me direct your
attention to section 701 of the bill
page 142 which reads in part the
Secretary of Homeland Security May Grant
parole to any alien who is a national of
the Republic of Cuba and is living in
the Republic of Cuba uh so for some
strange reason
you you don't want to use parole for
ukrainians
but you do want to use them for Cubans
who are according to this or exempt from
all restrictions that apply to every
other nationality uh in the rest of the
title so um it just seems kind of
strange to me can you explain why we
just kept the Cuban family reunification
parole program in place that's been a
long-standing program so we kept that in
place anyone else from around the world
it's a case like the laws the law it's a
case-by-case basis and the
administration can use that on a
case-by-case basis that's what we have
in the legislation so Afghanistan under
the Taliban seems
to to be a worse life for people in
Afghanistan than in Cuba why aren't why
aren't they carved out for humanitarian
parole again or for that matter why
isn't the Afghan adjustment act included
in this bill again we we stuck with what
the law is the laws the Cuban plan has
been in place for a long time we kept
that in place others the law says Case
by case basis we went back to that well
I mean I mean you're writing a law here
why not why not add Venezuelans
um or Nicaragua had a long debate about
that yeah and maybe what maybe would
have made it more but you're telling me
what's in the building sure no I'm just
I mean I it just seems that there's a
this is an example kind of a selective
compassion that you know makes one
wonder why I would argue it's adherence
to the rule of law That's What It Is
Well you know
which which reading we're treating
um you know one group of Nationals very
differently from others um from
countries that quite frankly are
experiencing far worse human rights
abuse Mr nether yeah I was just
wondering how uh Mr Jordan my other
Republican colleagues would would react
to uh proposal to make things uniform by
uh uh stopping the program for Cuban
making that an individual Case by case
basis as it is for Venezuela for Ukraine
Etc
I think we spoke on that with what we
passed on well let me
yeah well we're here now right I mean so
when we I mean we're the rules Community
we can make any amendment in order if we
want to my my fear is that
my Republican
friends who are chairs are are making uh
it clear that they want no amendments in
order but would would Mr Jordan you be
open or Mr McCall or Mr Green would you
be open to revisiting the uh the uh
issue with regard to
the ukrainians I mean there's there is
an amendment I mean I missed John Paul
offered an amendment she's offered it
again uh would you I'm not even asking
you to support it but would you be open
to having it brought to the floor so
there could be a debate and people could
vote however they wanted to if Mr Nadler
offered an amendment to get rid of the
Cuban family reunification parole I
would oppose that and I don't know if
you're going to make it yeah that was on
my question my question was if there's
an amendment there's no amendment that I
know of right now um uh that's pending
on the Cuban humanitarian parole but
there is one on the Ukrainian one uh
Miss jayapal is that amendment I mean
would would you be okay would you be you
could you can oppose it but would you be
open to allowing us to bring it to the
floor so that we can debate it and
people could vote up either way on it
would you be up would you be open to
that I think if I could chip in uh you
did you want me to or I mean all three
my perspective on this is that the
current crisis is because we're
violating the laws on how the Asylum
process should be working
and that's why people are pouring into
the country because they see all the
exceptions that are being made and and
so I think the point of this legislation
that came out of the Judiciary side is
just go back to the way the laws are
written but there's a difference as you
know between Asylum and humanitarian
parole
and we are and the question the
conversation was about that you're
making an exception for Cubans on
humanitarian parole that you extend to
no other nationality
um we have ukrainians who are
experiencing uh the most horrific
circumstances due to Putin's war crimes
against them isn't that the whole nature
of the Asylum process a person is being
persecuted by their country or whatever
I mean that's the whole point of the
Asylum process there's a difference
between Asylum and humanitarian parole
um Assam you have to have a well-founded
fear of persecution many of the
ukrainians who are here right now
who are being you're here under this
program that the white Administration
has extended may not necessarily fit the
strict criteria of a well-founded fear
of persecution but we know but we know
that it would be dangerous to send them
home
um there are a number of nationalities
that fit into that category
um and so there is there is a difference
that's one of the reasons why we have
temporary protected status for certain
groups of immigrants because the
situation in their country is is
terrible and it is potentially dangerous
but they may not fit that criteria so
there are two things so on the Asylum
stuff as Mr Castro pointed out the build
is before us
um is quite harsh you use the example of
a uighur of fleeing China coming to our
border and being forced to stay in
Mexico
um so that's that's one thing but we're
talking about humanitarian parole and so
all I'm asking you is
would you you don't have to vote for it
is whether or not the giant Paul
Amendment which basically says uh that
the ukrainians who are here
um you know can basically remain here
and that this program will continue for
them
can actually we bring an amendment to
the floor that would do that you could
vote however you want to and you can
check with your team and staff and come
up with all kinds of talking points why
it's a bad idea but I think that you
know given the fact that we are making
an exception for one group of Nationals
I mean there is a
horrific brutal Savage war going on in
Ukraine
um I don't know does anyone want to
um war crimes hearing yeah and it I
agree with you you and I both agree
um I think hr2 though clearly says that
individuals are apriled in the United
States are protected
in in this bill and I don't know how
more plain language I can make it right
so what about the ones that would come
so
if you're here now yeah then you you're
okay but it but I mean we that's
assuming that Putin's war of aggression
stops so if you come tomorrow you know
let's say this bill becomes law today so
you come tomorrow you're out of luck
it's because I mean why would why would
we why why why wouldn't we why would we
be so
why would we do this Castro political
Asylum I'm sorry no no Asylum is always
available on a case-by-case basis right
and it's really hard to get
um and um you know I you know we have
dealt with with immigrants and refugees
who have fled some of the most horrific
situations who don't quite meet the
standard to be able to prove um to
the courts that in fact they have a
well-funded fear of position it is a
very very high standard
and you know Putin fear of the CCP
persecuting uh weaker Muslims I think
that's why we set up political Asylum
fear of persecution but I wanted to say
ranking member I think I don't think
fear of Putin I mean you know to me I
don't think fear of Putin qualifies for
political asylum in our courts yeah Mr
Castro
really quick just to give some context
and why your question is incredibly
important uh people on parole need to
renew their parole each year
so current Parolees it's true would
write out the year but the new criteria
in hr2 this legislation would make them
ineligible for renewal so it's true that
the people here would continue on for
the year every year but the coming year
they're gone so that's what's at stake
for each of those communities that I
mentioned and one of them that you were
just talking about and why why would why
would we even
do that to the ukrainians who have fled
this terrible violence uh in unrest and
you I mean like what what do people
think of Mr Nadler I'd simply point out
that uh when you're talking about parole
for ukrainians I mean in addition to
what you just said about the the year
the ukrainians want to go home
they want to stay here only until that
war ends and they can go home this is
not a class of people who want to stay
here we're not talking about uh or we
may be talking about a few people who
claim political Asylum but for the and
and and they should be subject to the
normal Asylum requirements but we're
talking for the most part 99 about
people who want to go home
who may come here last year or in the
last few months since the invasion in
the last year or next month or the month
after that or however long this war
lasts but want to go home as soon as
it's safe to do so and and the war is
over and that's what uh is prevented by
this bill right so if I understand this
correctly
um
if if this bill were to become law today
if you are a Ukrainian who came here
tomorrow you would not be able to get
parole
um number one number two if you're a
Ukrainian who is here you have a year
and then what do you do what do you do
after a year
yeah
you've got to get out even if the war is
still going on yeah you got to get out
yeah
did anyone I mean District I mean am I
we misreading something here
I mean really
oh my God I I yield back
again before we proceed to the next
member for questions again I've been
advised that we need to switch out one
of our witnesses to any members have
questions specifically for Mr Castro
seeing none my friend is excused and uh
I think representative for Phyllis
McCormick will replace him at the pound
welcome
that will move for questions to
distinguish ranking member of the
committee my friends with Texas Mr
Burgess thanks I was going to win
Expressions
okay one of my friend yields Mr
reschenthal is recognized for questions
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Dr Burgess for yielding to me I will be
incredibly brief uh Mr chairman I'd like
to just ask for unanimous consent to
enter into the record in New York Times
article entitled alone and exploited
migrant children work brutal jobs across
the U.S at least published the 25th of
February of this year without objection
thank you Mr chairman uh briefly
chairman Greene would you like to just
talk about the fact that uh there's
children coming across the border this
New York Times article that's just been
edited in the record sites at about 85
000 that have just been lost no one
knows where they are and what kind of
impacts that might have on a migrant
child
yeah that uh New York Times article was
pretty uh damning of some of the
decisions made by the Secretary of
Homeland Security
um and the New York Times is not known
to be a conservative uh you know
reporting institution but they
specifically cite that the problem was a
decision made by my orcas to stop the
background checks on the sponsors
and by doing so these children are being
basically collected in 2030 uh in in to
one sponsor and then being used
um
an incredible inhumane conditions
um it's just appalling and so you take
the 85 000 that we don't even know about
I mean these are people that went
through the program were sponsored some
of them we actually know where they are
but they they pass through a sponsor
that never got a background check
they're 85 000 out there we don't know
where they are
and you you mentioned that you know
children in the pathway I mean we
visited on the border a rape tree
were the undergarments of the young
girls are placed on the tree as a trophy
to the cartel members who bring them
here
when you open the border and let's
assume for a second is it's well
intentioned
you you open the Border you cat
everything's catch and release
the cartels saw the opportunity
and so they seized that opportunity
and began trafficking humans for a price
uh
Homeland Security investigation says
it's making the cartels 15 billion
dollars a year
in that process incredible inhumane
things happen again Doctors Without
Borders not known to be a Conservative
Republican organization said 35 percent
of the women are raped
so if you open this up you create this
Mass wave your facilitating human
trafficking you are facilitating the
what's happening to these children
if we use the legal process
this doesn't happen
and that's the point of this is really
honestly there is on the Asylum side
especially just getting back to the way
the law has been written
so
um I it's a tragedy honestly of epic
proportions and thanks for asking the
question hey Mr chairman I appreciate it
without a yield back
very much when I go to my other friend
from Pennsylvania my scanners recognized
for any questions she cares to post
thank you
um as as I hope this discussion has
demonstrated uh immigration importer
security are pretty complex issues and
as such they require nuanced and
comprehensive Solutions unfortunately
neither of those terms describes hr2
it's pretty clear that our colleagues
don't actually want to promote
meaningful reforms that are required to
secure the Border or fix our broken
immigration system instead we've got a
completely unworkable Bill and without
any real solutions we have instead
inflammatory rhetoric conspiracy
theaters and theories and political fear
designed to stoke fear and chaos
chaos um we saw how the failed and
inhumane immigration policies of the
previous administration weakened our
economy undermined our moral standing in
the world inflicted permanent harm on
migrant children and their families and
didn't make us any safer hr2 would waste
American taxpayer dollars building a
border wall that experts have testified
time and time again will not solve our
border issues instead we should be
investing in infrastructure the ports of
Entry where 90 percent of Fentanyl and
illicit drug smuggling is actually
happening and most troubling of all this
legislation puts children In Harm's Way
even as our colleagues claim that they
want to protect children it opens the
door to jailing kids indefinitely bars
them from seeking Asylum and denies them
access to representation that they need
to navigate our complicated immigration
system
during my legal career I spent decades
working on immigration cases and I know
the system is broken but I also
understand the realities many of those
arriving at our borders face
I represented kids and other Asylum
Seekers who've come to the U.S to flee
gang activity political violence abuse
starvation trafficking and other
exploitation people risked their lives
to come here because the situation in
their home countries is so horrific
for all of those reasons these
conditions have been building for
decades this bill does nothing to
address those conditions during markup
in judiciary and again today our
colleagues have tried to justify
Provisions that would endanger and
inflict harm on migrant children by
saying they wanted to send them safely
home ignoring the fact that the whole
reason they migrated was because home
was not safe and in many cases home
didn't exist these kids were orphans
their families had already migrated
so you know we need to recognize both
the conditions that people are fleeing
and the meaningful contributions that
immigrants make to our country we
benefit from the talent and tax dollars
that result from functioning Pathways
for work and immigration we need doctors
care workers agricultural workers
researchers and more to make our economy
work we need the tax dollars from
younger workers to keep our social
security system solvent
so it's to all of our benefit to provide
functioning Pathways for people to enter
the US lawfully this bill does nothing
to fix our immigration system so I I
deeply oppose its passage out of
committee ranking member Nadler I think
you had something you wanted to add yes
thank you very much I just want to uh
comment on uh what chairman McCall said
about that New York Times report 85 000
children are not lost once HHS releases
children to their sponsors part of their
post-release services are a follow-up
phone call
if three phone calls go unanswered the
children are marked as unreachable on a
spreadsheet I don't know that any of us
answer every unknown phone call we
receive the same situation happens under
the Trump Administration and Obama's DPC
director provided the same explanation
thank you and I I know from experience
with representing kids in this situation
they are most often released to custody
of a relative so
um you know should we have more services
to address the needs of Migrant children
Social Services representation
absolutely but I'm afraid the 85 000
talking point is as
someone call it Malarkey
representative Thompson was there
something you wanted to add
uh yes and uh thank the chair for
allowing me to sit um for the most part
I've heard the comments and I just like
for the record to reflect that the bill
we're talking about today
uh and the section pertaining to
Homeland
um there was nothing about unaccompanied
children in it so it's
it's that part that I think that we need
to understand our community spent those
16 plus hours and there was nothing
about unaccounted children in the bill
uh as important is
um we offered a good number of
amendments that we thought should have
been considered not a single Democratic
amendment was accepted we wanted to
increase the number of people working at
the border that was turned down we
wanted to level the pay of people
working at the border that was turned
down a number of efforts
to make the the the climate of the
employee is better because they have
people working side by side in many
instances
who are federal employees who are making
different salaries for the most part uh
doing similar work so uh I look forward
to the chairman going forward with this
bipartisan effort it's just that it
didn't manifest itself in this bill we
got it 15 minutes before the deadline to
consider and and we'll look forward
to the bipartisanship that we have
historically had in this committee and
that this bill is a radical departure
from that uh bipartisanship
thank you I think we did see the parts
about the unaccompanied minors in the
Judiciary markup and we only went for
about 15 hours so you worked harder than
we did but
um we similarly offered uh
dozens of amendments which were not
accepted
um the part about unaccompanied minor
children was particularly troubling
given how vulnerable these kids are and
it it if they're going to be
incarcerated as suggested by the bill
then clearly homeland security has to
deal with where they are placed I mean
what this bill does do is probably a
huge Boon for the private prison
industry which will reap Untold benefits
from all the incarceration that is
proposed by this bill not something I
would recommend well you know we keep
them for 72 hours and after that the law
says we have to pass them on and that
becomes the the burden of HHS so DHS is
out of the business in short order and
all of what's being discussed about
children becomes a function of HHS not
DHS I think that's under the floor as
decision
as introduced would gut the Flores
decision that's right so that's one of
the big objections to it
um I think at this point I'd yield back
thank you thank you very much we're now
moved to my good friend distinguished
Vice chairman of the committee Mr
Burgess
thank you Mr chairman I just want to
take um before we get to the business of
the day
probably within the last hour of that
meeting down the White House has wrapped
up and uh I don't know how it turned out
or what to expect on the uh discussions
of the debt limit but I do know this Mr
chairman without your stewardship of
getting that bill the limit save and
grow Bill through the rules committee
and onto the floor they wouldn't be
having that discussion so incredibly
important to get that bill passed two
weeks ago
that gives me optimism that
HR One having such a
a good position now in in getting the
debt limit discussions going hr2
can perhaps have
an equal amount of gas in the tank for
getting a border security bill
or border security under discussion
Mr Jordan I I don't want to imply that I
wasn't listening but maybe I wasn't
listening as carefully as I should have
been as you started your remarks you
gave us a recitation of some numbers
yeah of
what this country has seen in the last
two and a half years well just the last
weekend 26 000 and 72 hours in in one
sector in Texas so
um 5 million over the 28 months of the
Biden Administration so you could go on
and on uh but the big number let me just
stop you there five million over the
months of the Biden Administration
is anyone aware of a comparable
situation in any country where five
million people in two years and a little
more
have been infused into the population I
mean it well and that's on top of we
normally take what 1.1 million people
legally each year yeah yeah and I will
tell you what one of the uh the sheriffs
who testified at a hearing he said 28
years of law enforcement as a sheriff in
On the Border in Arizona he said he's
never seen it this bad in 28 years he's
never seen it this bad and frankly he
said in the previous administration it
was as good as he's ever seen it so in
28 years of law enforcement on our
Southern border he says right now it's
as bad as it's ever been better or worse
and and then here is the problem and why
it is so critically important that
people see a seriousness about a border
security bill in 48 hours
what has been untenable may become
astonishing in its level point and we've
seen the Drone pictures of people that
are sort of waiting their their time to
because of this notion of them when
title 42 expires there really will be no
limits on the amount of people that can
come into this country is that correct
yeah and the one thing when you have
that volume of folks coming across the
border coming into our nation
there are going to be some bad bad
people and we know of 200 on the
terrorist watch list and never forget a
year ago when secretary Marcus was in
front of the Judiciary Committee we
asked him a question at the time it was
only 42 I believe now it's 200. time 42
we said what is the status of those
individuals and you may remember his
answer because everyone Watson
remembered he said I don't know he
didn't know if they were detained he
didn't know whether and you're coming in
from the Judiciary Committee as the
Secretary of Homeland Security Homeland
Security security of the nation you
should know the status of the 42
individuals who are on the terrorist
watch list and he did it and now that
number is is is five times what it was
at the time that he testified
so one of the other things that's being
discussed currently down on the border
is the
you know will will be the inability of
the ngos to handle the number of people
that are dropped off at their locations
now historically I mean multiple trips
down to Macallan I've seen it over and
over and over again where a notice to
appear is given and the folks are
dropped off at Sacred Heart Church in
downtown McAllen they're giving a fanny
pack with a bottle of water and a bus
ticket and and good luck to you but now
those ngos will be overwhelmed Catholic
Charities will be overwhelmed and
basically people will just be turned
loose on the street corners and hope to
catch a bus somewhere and
has there been any discussion either in
judicial or Homeland Security about how
that's going to be handled what's going
to be
what's going to be the mechanism of
control on the streets of those border
communities
either one of you do you use the right
word doctor the word is overwhelmed and
that's what's happening and now the bite
Administration is talking about
secretary Mark is talking about if I
could they're overwhelmed now yeah in 48
hours weeks time it's going to be
astonishing at the level the president
did act act you know you're sending
fifteen hundred military down there to
process but again
let me interrupt you there yeah and my
our governor my Governor said fifteen
hundred and these are people with
pencils in their hand too that's correct
they're there to process people they're
not there to stop anyone and that just
encourages more
and that number should be fifteen
thousand or fifty thousand
as a with with enforcement capabilities
instead these are clerical they're
processors yes
so
add to the incentive okay yeah and
really that's what's that's really
what's the worst of it Mr Jordan you
chairman Jordan you uh referenced uh a
term that a lot of people may not be
familiar with and we we know from past
experience there are so many people that
hang on the the television televised
rules committee hearings like can can
you explain the Darian Gap to people who
might not know where they come through
and it's it's it's and they're they're
already massing there so um you know and
we've we've all seen them
we've all seen the Caravans of folks
coming and you know look we all say we
don't fault anyone for wanting to get to
the greatest country ever but you got to
do it legally you got to do it the right
way and you got to have an
Administration understands that this one
doesn't but the Darian Gap is that area
of real estate that exists south of
Panama between Panama the ismos of
Panama
South America but it is also some of the
most ungoverned and Lawless and
dangerous real estate on the face of the
earth is that not correct yeah we've had
I've not been there personally but we've
had members members go down there and
see for themselves I think chairman
green has been there but yeah that's
that's what we're talking about and
they're
estimates are now thousands are already
massing there to make the track and the
the burdensome and Troublesome Truck for
uh North
well I
again the the
policies and and what this
Administration has followed has only
exacerbated the problem and
it's fixing to get worse on a level that
I don't think anyone
really can adequately
anticipate
um I also Mr chairman I had some uh we
heard about the the New York Times
article I have a second New York Times
article I'd like to submit for the
record
my migrant children were put to work and
the United States ignored the warnings
and Mr Thompson is exactly correct three
days without objection three days after
or after 72 hours those children are
turned over Department of Health and
Human Services
and the issue there has been the
throughput and became so critical
get those kids in and get them out
quickly and you heard references to
secretary Becerra saying this could be a
Henry Ford type assembly line in this
article from The New York Times Susan
Rice has quoted as saying This is BS
these kids are coming here just because
they're but that
This is BS Mrs writes wrote
what is leading to voluntary separation
is our generosity to unaccompanied
children
I mean that it's pretty harsh and that
is in this Administration that was a
domestic policy advisor until a week and
a half ago in this Administration so I
do want this to be made part of the
record and then as part of a hearing
that we held
in the oversight investigations on
Energy and Commerce which does have
jurisdiction over the office of refugee
resettlement
um the Inspector General came into that
hearing
and they had prepared a report from the
and I would also like to submit for the
record the office of Inspector General
operational challenges within Orr and
the Orr emergency intake site at Fort
Bliss hindered case management for
children without objection
so on page 15 of this report
headline is the office of refugee
resettlement issued field guidance that
removed certain steps of the sponsor
screening process across Orr facilities
potentially increasing children's risk
of release to unsafe sponsors
subparagraph according to Federal field
specialist supervisors some Orr field
guidance issued from March of 2021
through June of 2021 was developed
without adequate input from Orr staff
with expertise in child welfare well let
me translate that for you
originally
Orr could only release children in their
custody
to family members
or
those relatives after appropriate
vetting
but they changed the guidance it was a
field
guidance that was issued in March of
2021 where they didn't need to take
those protective steps anymore so I
actually believe chairman McCall that
that 85 000 number that you referenced
when we actually know that number is
going to be significantly higher because
secretary mayorkas unilaterally Changed
by field guidance not something that
went through the administrative
procedures act certainly not something
that came through a legislative
Committee in regular order but by field
guidance said we don't need to do this
work anymore and we can send these kids
wherever the heck it is we want and that
is what has led to the crisis that the
New York Times has has published these
articles
we have to have a secure border
after we have a secure order we can talk
about any number of immigration reforms
any one of us would like to see but we
do not have a secure border and in fact
the border is becoming less secure by
the hour and over these next 48 hours
again I submit we are going to see a
crisis of really really unheralded
proportions so again Mr chairman I do
want to ask that both of these uh Dr can
I respond because I have to say this is
what worries me these children that come
in are being sent to stash houses
essentially and I lived this for a long
time but this is the worst and so
they're not vetted the sponsors aren't
vetted properly you got 10 maybe 20 kids
going to the same house
this is not a
mom and pop thing not a mom Pop Shop
really it's a it's a Trafficking
Organization that's happening inside
this country right now and it's the
children that are being affected by this
policy and if I recall correctly it was
the Houston chief of police that said
dominance not to Homeland Security but
Orr you're releasing all of these
children to the same address
and you don't even know
where that is and and there was no
vetting of the process and secretary
mayorkas
issued field guidance
not going through normal administrative
procedures not going through the
legislative branch here's the field
guidance we can just kind of send them
wherever we want and that is nuts and
we're asking for trouble we're asking
for more disasters but as bad as it is
today a week from now
there's no telling how what the numbers
are that we're going to see we all know
they're going up they're high now but
they're going to get higher and more and
more people are going to be hurt thank
you Mr chairman I'll yield back thank
you very much we now go for questions to
my good friend from New Mexico Miss
Ledger Hernandez thank you ever so much
chair Cole for giving me the opportunity
and before I get into questioning I
wondered if a ranking member Nadler
might want to respond to some of those
that those questions that we were just
hearing well thank you very much I just
want to make one point Title Five of
this bill will result in long-term
Detention of children this title
eliminates the current requirement that
DHS transfer children within 72 hours to
HHS custody during the Border surge of
2018 under the Trump Administration we
saw horrible images of many children
held in cpb custody in crowded Northern
Squad conditions for lengthy periods of
time if this bill is implemented it's
title five of the spills implemented the
lengthy Detention of children in such
hard conditions would become standard
operating procedure I thank the general
will the general lady
response actually I want to respond to
that first and I think that I've been at
the border following under the Biden
Administration and I saw the way in
which our Uh custom Patrol officers were
working really hard to make sure that
those children were processed as quickly
as possible they were moving them into
non-profits uh where they were being
well cared for and the problem is one of
funding there had been supplemental
funding to provide for this and we need
to continue to provide for that
supplemental funding and what we have to
do is fix the broken immigration system
and I think that's what we all agree on
but we should not fix it on top of
the backs of these poor children and I
was as I was there at the border and and
you might appreciate this uh
representative Burgess as I was there at
the border I recalled another
story
another story of a refugee another story
of somebody of a mother who was going to
send her child to a place that she
believed he would be safe
because she knew that where she lived he
would not be safe
and so that mother gathered her baby and
she put him in a small raft and put him
on the Nile River and sent him
Downstream because if she would have
kept him at home she knew he would die
that baby was welcomed that baby was
Moses and I call upon us here I call
upon my Republicans
to think about the story of Moses and
imagine what it must be like to be a
parent
who sends her child North through the
Darion Gap through all of these tragic
circumstances because they want their
children to live
they want their children to live
earlier we heard from representative
Joaquin that that was what was written
on the application for his grandmother
that that
grandmother was sent here in order to
live and I think that that is a really
key thing of what we must do now I want
to address the issue that uh Dr Burgess
did raise with regards to the debt
ceiling
um because it strikes me
that comprehensive immigration reform
something like the U.S uh citizenship
act would spur economic growth indeed
the last time Congress seriously
considered comprehensive immigration
reform in 2013 the CBO estimated it
would increase gross domestic product by
1.4 trillion so if we're serious about
addressing economic issues in our fiscal
house we would actually pass
comprehensive immigration reform the
kind of Reform that would make it
possible for those who are now here
working those who are now here starting
businesses but without papers that they
would then be able to contribute to our
economy I actually am old enough to have
participated in the immigration reform
and control act as an attorney helping
those who were going to gain lawful
status through the irca what we saw was
a boost in economic activity from there
a significant boost
when
but let's talk about bills that we've
actually put forth and where do we get
that support from when I'm in New Mexico
I'm as I let everybody know I have a
world District so I'm talking to my
Farmers I'm talking to my home builders
and what I hear them say over and over
again is they want us to pass
immigration reform that addresses their
need for workers that addresses their
need for workers on the ranches the
farmers that allows dreamers to stay in
the U.S I'm going to ask each of the
chairs yes or no uh did does this bill
that we're presently put before is it is
does it address the need for additional
um workers that we have in our society
perhaps I'll start with you
um
this is a border security Bill not an
immigration bill as I understand it once
we once we get border security we can we
can fix the immigration the problem is
is has been exemplified by this
administration's
unsecuring the Border it creates an
incentive that drives more and more
folks into the country if you fix the
immigration system and provide with an
unsecured border it's just even more so
that's why our argument I think uh Mr
Burgess was or you know Congressman
Burgess was making this point earlier
you know let's get border security and
then we'll let's let's talk about
immigration reform but this bill uh by
itself thank you very much thank you so
very much because I think that that
really is a a difference of opinion that
I think that what we're
looking is that
and do both that we should do both
because in order to do comprehensive you
need to address both and you need to
address those things that are most
impactful to our issues which I'll get
to in a bit by the way did you vote for
the bipartisan Farm Workforce
modernization act uh last cycle
look I don't remember
let me tell you that bipartisan Farm
worker modernization act I am that was
one of those pieces of legislation that
was worked out by those most impacted
right it was worked on by the United
Farm Workers and they came to the table
and they told us you know what it
doesn't have everything we want but it
has what we need it was worked on by
those who are whose whose businesses
depend on those workers so it was both
business was at the table Farm Workers
were at the table we had a bill it was
bipartisan Mr chair I don't believe you
did vote you did not vote for it and
actually do
chair uh chairmancology recall have you
voted for it
I don't believe I did
exactly it did and and chair Jordan I
know you didn't vote for it either but
but those are yeah but there's some
reason in there but those are the kind
s that if we did right that is by
Artisan we would start addressing so
many of the issues we have especially in
areas in rural areas like mine and I'm
looking over at our ranking member
Thompson you and I often talk about the
issues that we need addressed in rural
areas you and I uh you know we represent
uh big rural areas tell me like how does
what we're looking at now impact your
world communities well thank you very
much uh I have a large agricultural
District that depends significantly on
the migrant labor force to harvest our
crops uh without it uh those crops could
not be harvested to be to be honest with
you whether the individuals are coming
and from the southern border or from the
northern border or wherever in addition
to that uh our challenge
is uh we have a value system as
Americans that we have to uphold the
homeland security part of this bill
would say that those ngos that were
talked about earlier that if one person
they helped turn out to be illegal they
could get no additional DHS funds and if
if in my situation I have a working
disaster in my district right now if the
Red Cross or another NGO uh uh trying to
help people with lodging or whatever if
they are cited
then they lose all the funding
Associated uh with DHS so we put a lot
of people out out out of work there are
some other issues associated with it and
and I know there's some some challenges
that we have to look at but those ngos
play a significant part
in addressing a lot of issues along the
southern border and for us to to to try
to punish them
for their humanitarian efforts would not
be good we often refer to those ngos and
to the many volunteers who work with
them who have huge Hearts imagine them
imagine the compassion
The Compassion that these organizations
have thank you chairman Jordan for for
nodding because you know what these ngos
are facing and you know they have big
hearts right but they have a lot of
volunteers and they are there to help
out uh around uh she representative
Sheila uh
Sheriff Lucas McCormick sorry if I mess
up the name tell me about your
experience and how you see this as
actually
I think are you our only representative
in Congress who who is a migrant from
Haiti am I correct on that thank you so
much I'm the only member of Congress as
a Democrat who's ever been a defender of
Haitians my parents came from Haiti
fleeing a dictatorship and one thing I
wanted to make very clear is that the
incentive to leave your home to come
through water walking millions of people
don't make it to this country and they
take that risk and it's only because you
have no other choice
it's pressed could you hear me it's low
okay so what I was saying um the
incentives this bill when it deals with
the Foreign Affairs um part of it it
doesn't deal with the actual incentive
no one is incentivized to come to the
United States because of the policies
it's because of you have no other choice
you're suffering in your country you are
being persecuted but what we do have an
opportunity to do is actually add and
create bills that would deal with the
root causes when we look at what's going
on and why we have such high migration
patterns in fact it's because of the
post-covet world coupled with the rise
of authoritarian regimes that are trying
to pop up throughout Latin America and
in South America in addition to that the
games that are growing and to be quite
honest with you are in action in the
last Administration with dealing with
our foreign neighbors and being good
partners we have an opportunity right
now to have bilateral relationships
multi-lateral relationships and funding
helping those group causes especially
when it comes to food insecurities when
it comes to political insecurity we can
live up to our reputations at this
moment and be that Beacon of Hope for
all countries but we have to start with
doing what we do in foreign affairs
which is building and stepping in and
being the diplomats we can be and so
that's the problem I have with this bill
here this is actually not dealing with
incentives and I hear a lot of it like
we have incentive policies now to come
to the United States that is absolutely
incorrect the motivation to come to this
country is because of desperation and we
have to address that so when we look at
what we can do let's incentivize them to
stay home let's incentivize them to be
in their native land no one wants to
migrate to the United States especially
at this time you want to be in your
Homeland you want to be with your family
Millions die on this Trek Millions give
up their lives trying to get here they
understand the risk of being trafficked
women understand that they understand
the risk of their children being taken
from them but the other the risk is
being dismembered in your own country
the other risk is being torn apart
watching your child being raped in front
of you we've heard reports in Haiti of a
three-year-old being raped over and over
again where are our diplomatic efforts
where are we there trying to make sure
we have governance that's what this
portion has to be when we talk about
Foreign Affairs and we have to come back
to that and not surrender to the
rhetoric that we hear about what's
really incentivizing to have people come
to this country it is not because
because the borders open millions of
people are turned away and can never
come back we're not even really looking
at Asylum Seekers and giving them those
opportunities with this and so with that
I yield back thank you very much and I
think what you point out is that we're
not incentivizing actually the the
Trouble Is Us
Congress
Congress has failed to pass immigration
reform for decades the burden lies here
right and so we've had Republican
presidents
Bush kept talking about wanting to solve
this right we have Republican and
Democratic presidents talking about the
need to solve this and because we
haven't gotten a bipartisan agreement I
think it lies with us the blame lies
with us in Congress uh I'm chair McCall
I I am so sorry uh to hear of the uh the
funerals that your children had to
attend to those who lost to fentanyl New
Mexico has a very Highway of addiction
and overdose I often talk about the fact
that I lost two brothers to addiction
and so these are issues that are really
um hard for communities and and it's
ravaging our communities
um so so I I'm really sorry to hear that
and sorry to hear how close it has
struck to your own family in your own
home I guess when I think about it
though I go back to the the Cato
Institute study which actually
acknowledged that 90 percent of the
fentanyl that is being brought into the
United States is being bought through
our parts of Entry is being bombed by
United States citizens uh and with that
uh Mr chair I'd like to uh enter into
the record
um the September 14 since 2020 through
Cato Institute article fentanyl is
smuggled for U.S citizens by U.S
citizens not Asylum Seekers without
objection
and I think that that
um that when we think about that
that we need to really consider
seriously the the amendment by my own
colleague of um New Mexico uh represent
representative Vasquez who actually
would direct more money uh to the border
to increase the kind of technology that
we know that works at the border will
you be supporting representative
vasquez's amendment to direct more money
to the border for those kinds of
interdictions it's for non-intrusive
inspection technology for 305 million
dollars I can't speak to her Amendment
I'll tell you I do support technology
that can screen I think that's that's
smart border security you know policy
and you know I know for I've met with
the DEA administrator just a couple days
ago this is all coming from China and it
goes through one port in Western you
know Mexico and it spirals up into the
United States
and it's everywhere
yes absolutely everywhere and tip yeah
my good friend on the Foreign Affairs
committee chairman Meeks and I passed
marked up a bill on Haiti on
international law enforcement of the
sanctioning gang members on you know
dealing with the political situation and
I agree we got to deal with the root
cause of this as well my dear colleague
Mr Green has a bill on Central America
providing more private investment in
Central America because when you have
lawlessness and chaos and gangs and
Warlords in Haiti lack of opportunity
lack of opportunity you're going to
drive that magnet
and we're just saying the policy though
of political Asylum was pulling the
magnet into the United States as well
yeah so um so I
I think we have I
what I want to make sure is that when we
talk about fentanyl because I get
conventional when I go home I'm a border
state uh the issue of fentanyl gets
raised and I think because it gets
talked about all the time in
relationship to Asylum Seekers it gets
confusing I want to make sure everybody
knows the facts are clear
fentanyl is coming in through the ports
of Entry by 90 by uh United States
citizens and not by Asylum Seekers we do
not have little kids it's a border
security issue the border security thank
you thank you could I make a comment
about the numbers 90 though I mean Mardi
grad degrees in economics and so that if
you'll just bear with me just a second
about the math equation to come up with
that 90 percent
what what they're doing just to say that
90 of what is seized
happens is seized at the points of Entry
when you equate that to that's where 90
of the fentanyl comes into the United
States that's a false
uh correlation because
if that were the case there wouldn't be
fentanyl in the United States right I
mean so we it's it's 90 percent X is the
number seized over
that seized at the at the Crossing sites
is divided by the number seized at the
Crossing site plus the number seized not
at the Crossing site
leaves out the number that we don't know
because it didn't get seized
so you can't say that because 90 is
seized at the Crossing sites ninety
percent of the fentanyl is seized that
that's a a faulty mathematical equation
we have video
in our committee of coyotes wearing
backpacks camouflage and carpet shoes
pouring across ranchers on on game cam
or footage with fentanyl and and they
find the drop sites in Arizona I'm sure
they're in New Mexico as well where
hundreds of backpacks are found by law
enforcement empty at a drop site where
they're loading the Fentanyl and
bringing it in those numbers aren't in
the equation
so you you can you're accurate if you're
saying that ninety percent of what is
seized to seized at the ports of Entry
that's where we got all the people
looking
but if you say 90 of the fentanyl that
comes into the United States comes in at
a Port of Entry that's mathematically
Incorrect and I just want to make that
point Thank you thank you so very much
for it but I think that what it does say
and in fact what you just said is
backpack's been left and we actually
have seen under this Administration
increased uh interdiction of fentanyl so
there is an increased effort to address
the fentanyl coming in and the backpacks
that are being left by the courtyotas
and I think that we need to go after
them strong I mean they are hurt in my
community they're hurting your
communities they're hurting the United
States but when you look at whether it
is these Asylum Seekers who are bringing
it that's when you try to equate that
that's yeah I've never said those words
and I I agree with you there are people
who are legitimately want to come here
for for their better betterment I get
that the vast majority of people that
are coming are coming for their
betterment I understand that completely
the problem is is that with the open
border system we have the drug cartels
are taking advantage of it and so
they're and it was fascinating that
Merrick Garland said this was the cartel
strategy in testimony to the Senate that
they're massing people paid by the
paying coyotes at Crossing sites so that
they can sneak the Fentanyl and the bad
you know nefarious individuals other
between the ports of entry and that
secretary mayorka said he was unaware of
that story chairman green did you vote
for the debt uh ceiling Bill two weeks
ago to capture yes I did yeah we've got
to get ourselves as we know as as we
know we asked the department uh how
would this impact your ability to
continue to interdict and they said it
would lead to two thousand four hundred
fewer Frontline CBP law enforcement
officers uh representative Thompson
ranking member Thompson do you have some
thoughts on this conversation well uh
thank you very much first of all uh the
technology improvements we propose uh uh
in markup didn't get approved uh the
only issue from a technology standpoint
that the Homeland people are two-way
radios I mean that's kind of horse and
buggy you need it but uh we offered
intrusive uh scanning capability at our
ports of Entry that was turned down all
of the technological advances that we
clearly understand that would help
identify the Fentanyl and Other Drugs
coming across the border that was turned
down in terms of the statistics the
statistics uh that the Cato Institute
and other people talk about those are
statistics brought by the FBI uh uh the
other Regulatory Agencies who do this
for a living it's not a study so I think
those figures are accurate I real charge
is the homeland security part of this
bill uh you know puts at risk a lot of
opportunity to work with people who get
here uh uh ngos do a wonderful job
at that now everybody has
stories but the real part about it is as
we work
with the officials I think it's
important for us to come up with a
system
that's why my plea is with my chairman
now uh after this border Bill he's
publicly said we're going to do some
bipartisan legislation I really want to
see it because we have the history in
this committee on homeland to work that
out the last point is
um uh the poor to enter
are the prime place that the fentanyl
comes I mean that's that's it now the
other points I can't argue that but in
terms of the facts when you start
looking at the collection of of the the
fentanyl we capture them at the ports of
Interest I mean that's that's the facts
and so uh what people want to uh catch
more with the new technology uh if it
had been included in this bill we could
catch more uh we we didn't get it
included we offered to get uh some new
people hired we didn't get the new
numbers uh for additional people hired
in the past when we tried to get it uh
new people brought on board my
Republican colleagues voted against it
you know we need uh
good people working at the border and
and we can't turn down uh those
opportunities so uh we look forward to
working with them uh we have a problem
with drones
uh coming across the border uh we
produced a drone amendment in the markup
because our people working at the border
tells us uh drones uh now one of those
uh new technologies that bad people are
using and we need some anti-drone
technology to defeat we couldn't get his
approved so we continue to look at
technology but we have to look at it uh
in a forward manner not in the rear view
mirror
thank you representative Thompson and I
think that's what is so problematic
about this bill is that it's not a bill
that's been worked out in a bipartisan
fashion that looks at what the problem
is and says let's solve it rather than
let's create a political
messaging let's beat up on the president
this is not something that we should
turn into a political football it really
needs we need that kind of comprehensive
immigration reform we need the
comprehensive border security that looks
like at how they're all done I really am
looking forward to uh Karen green
um you know 70 percent of Americans uh
favor the DREAM Act and addressing the
fact that we have dreamers who are
doctors who are artists who are nurses
who are teachers who are so many amazing
things but we cannot get the DREAM Act
passed uh uh uh chairman Greene when you
talk about being ready to support others
will are you supportive of the DREAM Act
I'd have to look at it I haven't seen
that bill I don't know the exact wording
and I just like I tell the government
Affairs people in the lobbyists who come
into my office and say a great idea I
don't say yes until I read that entire
bill so I'd have to read it and take a
look at it thank you chairman green we
have introduced that I
answer of the one last year last cycle
in this cycle but that act has been
introduced numerous times and it usually
basically says the same thing so
hopefully we'll get your support for it
and because I think that that's what we
need to do is be real honest and support
the things that we know Americans want
and then you know I really do appreciate
the reference to
scripture uh in terms of how we look at
the refugees and Asylum Seekers and
those who are crossing our border uh and
it reminded me once again going to
Exodus to not do not oppress a foreigner
you yourselves know how it feels to be
foreigners because once you were and in
many ways we were all immigrants to this
country
um you know Deb Holland you know was not
and represent chairman Cole and Cherise
Davis but so many of the others of us we
we depend on immigrants to make our
country diverse and vibrant and
economically strong and so I hope that
we remember that and that we remember
the treat uh our Latinos are Asians or
Haitians with the kind of respect and
you know ah that they deserve because
they go through so much representative
vergas I am sorry I got caught up in the
story of Moses and and didn't yield as I
had said I would uh so I will yield now
thank you I just wanted to point out to
determine our ranking member Nadler
thank goodness he's ranking member
Nadler um
your reference to the previous
administration
but it was actually in 2014 in the Obama
Administration when those horrific
pictures of kids in cages were first
published was our colleague Henry
Cuellar who surreptitiously took
pictures at the Ursula unit in in
McAllen Texas and furthermore
when first many of those kids were moved
to Lackland Air Force Base in San
Antonio just to deal with the
overwhelming numbers at that time that
we're coming in
Anna Hernandez who was the first lady of
Honduras
came to San Antonio and she was asked
why don't you want your children back
and she said of course we want our
children back and so the Obama
Administration accommodated them and and
flew those children back to Honduras
it had the immediate effect of rapidly
diminishing the number
of unaccompanied minors from Honduras
that showed up in America so to Mr
Jordan's point it does work that was a
that was a policy that was asked for by
the Obama Administration allowed to be
used in the Obama Administration it
actually worked
and all we're asking is for a similar
path forward in this in this bill this
is a border security Bill not an
immigration Bill fix the Border we can
have the discussions about immigration
reform
back in 1986 the Simpson mazoli bill
because of the double cross that
occurred then
told President Reagan you give us
amnesty and we'll we'll we'll fix the
security problems well they got the
amnesty and they never fixed the
security problems most of the people
that I represent do not want to take
that risk again I yield back thank you
representative Burgess uh uh Frank
remember do you want to add anything to
that or shall we move on
uh and I I will move on but I think the
the
image that is seared in so many
Americans Minds is is is those babies
um and those children torn from their
parents doing the prior Administration
uh and I just hope that we remember that
and reject it always because that is not
who we are we are much better than that
America is much better than that uh and
so with that I yield back thank you
thank you gentlelady before we proceed
to the next member for questions I
understand we need once again to switch
out one of our Witnesses any members
have any questions specifically for
chairman Jordan
I think his replacement is is more than
capable of answering questions and I
just showed up and I know is eager to
join us so thank you for seeing none
without objection my friends excused Mr
McClintock will replace chairman Jordan
on the panel
and with that we'll go to my friend from
Minnesota for any questions he may have
from them
thank you Mr chair and and I was going
to I think first I just really wanted to
point out my colleague from New Mexico
talked about
uh you know comprehensive immigration
reform and all kinds of things in the
bill from last year but um
I just wanted to point out that the the
Democrats were in control of everything
last year and still failed to do it
um you know it did pass out of the house
but
um I I so I just wanted to point that
out so when you say we need to pass it
you had the opportunity last year and
weren't able to with the with the
representative for just a moment yeah
okay well we did pass it out at the
house that was bipartisan we could not
get enough Republican Senators because
of uh the filibuster uh we needed more
Republican Senators so yes we uh in the
house we were in control but as you know
the Senate has its own rules and we had
Democratic support but we did not have
sufficient Republican support in the
Senate but so thank you yes but then it
must not have been a bill that could
have bipartisan support if you couldn't
get it but we won't go on that I just
had to point it out I just had to point
that yes will yield for an observation
in 2010 in a lame duck session of
Congress the house once again passed
Senator Durbin's Bill about addressing
the dreamers they did not pass it in the
Senate with three Republican yes votes
and the reason they didn't pass it in
the Senate remember they had a 60 vote
majority in the Senate at the time five
Democratic senators voted no the last
time they had the opportunity was
swinging a Miss thank you I yield back
and and I just wanted to point that out
because we keep talking about how we
need this but you had the opportunity
and couldn't do it
um but uh Mr McClintock I I don't mean
to put you on the spot just the second
you get here but I did have some
questions you know I'm from an AG
district and there was some discussion
before you got here about some of the uh
you know uh the effects on the AG
industry that this bill might have and
you know we're struggling like AG
industry and many Industries are
struggling with Workforce issues and I
was just hoping that maybe to change the
uh change the direction of the
discussion and can you talk about some
of the provisions in the bill that could
potentially help the AG industry and
Farmers with uh with reliable access and
retaining reliable Workforce first of
all it repeals the adverse effect uh
wage rate regulations of the Biden
Administration that the gentleman's wank
on
it re can you hear that yeah okay yeah
it repeals the uh adverse effect uh uh
rate a wage rate regulations
um uh there's also a provision I believe
was agreed to in negotiations uh the
night before last uh that um uh uh
postpones uh the uh provisions of
e-verify until it could be certified
there would be no adverse effect on Farm
labor supplies
so so there are some reasonable things
in here that would help with those
issues oh yes yes
absolutely thanks to the good work of a
lot of our representatives from
agricultural districts thank you and uh
you know I appreciate the repeal of the
wage rule of the of the rage and some
bureaucrats in the Department of Labor
with no experience in the field uh
decided to set a so-called modest rule
that would increase costs for farmers in
my district by nearly 15
this is on top of the regulatory on slot
brought on by this Administration over
the past two years two and a half years
excuse me as well as crippling inflation
and I'm deeply concerned about the
administration's complete lack of
attention to the needs of Rural America
and so I'm really glad that this was
included
um and I just wanted to maybe talk a
little bit and of course then my
computer freezes up but you know maybe
just some how how that border security
not only in the way of fentanyl but if
we secure the Border it's it helps our
communities all the way from Minnesota
uh all over the country and maybe we can
just refocus and talk a little bit about
the issues that are caused when we have
um you know a free-flowing border well
again first of all the numbers are
already staggering and I think they're
afraid they're going to be dwarfed this
week as as the borders completely
collapse before our eyes uh in the last
20 we had secure borders on inauguration
day uh by mid-afternoon we didn't Joe
Biden repealed the uh a trump era remain
in New Mexico policy he uh
um uh uh ordered a cessation of any kind
of activity on the border wall uh and he
ordered ice to stop enforcing
deportation orders about 1.2 million
deportation orders people have gone
through the whole process been ordered
deported and those orders are not being
carried out uh but the number that
they've allowed into the country uh
deliberately 2.1 million that is larger
than the state of Nebraska while the
border patrol has been taking names and
changing diapers on the border
overwhelmed by these numbers 1.5 million
known gotaways these people we watched
on video across the border are tracked
crossing the border
um uh but evaded any kind of
interception or capture that's 1.5
million that is the uh larger than the
state of Hawaii that's all in just 28
months
um uh the I've never understood how the
Democrats believe that our schools are
going to be improved by packing
classrooms with non-english speaking
students or how are hospitals are going
to uh uh be made more accessible by
flooding emergency rooms with the
illegals demanding care or how our
communities are made safer by
introducing cartels into our
neighborhoods and uh and then making it
all but impossible to remove criminal
illegal alien through their Sanctuary
policies I don't understand how 300
deaths a day from fentanyl coming across
the border that's the equivalent of two
uh 737 airliners crashing every single
day in this country and and they don't
seem to be the least bit upset about
that uh what are we doing to to to to
Working Families by flooding the um a
labor market with cheap illegal labor
and
of the the the impact of these policies
is is being felt by every American is
every border patrol officers has told me
uh they don't stay here they go
throughout the country and now you're
seeing the social safety net meant to
help Americans in need collapsing before
our eyes and you're hearing that not not
from Fox News you're hearing it from
Lori Lightfoot and uh of other
Democratic Mayors across the uh country
well and I appreciate that and I I've
just
the the concern is Nationwide about the
about the on the issues that come along
with and the crime that comes along with
that open border and I I mean we all
were back in our districts last week and
I was talking to a sheriff in rural
Minnesota in a small County and he was
talking about the Fentanyl and they had
it there was a serial killer uh uh just
caught in in Davis California uh came
here as a UAC he was part of the DACA
program apparently
but um but I will um
given that I Frozen up a little bit I
will my computer I will yield back Mr Mr
chairman uh yesterday unanimous consent
request to insert on the record a
statement uh that explains how the
e-verify uh mandatory program will force
many of our Farms to go under so without
objection there's no spin here
a gentleman from South Carolina is
recognized for any questions he cares to
ask
that that'd be fine well gentlelady from
Indiana is recognized for her questions
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Norman um thank you for coming here to
testify today I appreciate your time
um the Biden border cross crisis has
made every state a border state
including the state of Indiana where I'm
from
uh
I visited the Border earlier this year I
went to Eagle Pass Texas and Uvalde
I visited the unaccompanied minors
processing center where I encountered 10
unaccompanied teenagers between the ages
of 14 and 17.
and one five-year-old girl
there was a 16 year old female holding
on to this five-year-old girl
cradling her in her arms
and we spoke to these children
and uh asked is this your sister
she said no they handed her to me as I
crossed the border she has no family
border patrol agents let us know that
after the new policies under this
Administration these kids are really
just handed a piece of paper where
they're supposed to be taken once they
get here
I worked in child services for about the
first few years of my career we couldn't
send foster children across state lines
without a significant elaborate process
to verify when they get there they're
going to be safe
so I don't know if the number is 85 000
kids Dr Burgess I imagine it's probably
higher than that of kids that we don't
know what happened to them
but what I know is that we're not
DNA testing maybe we're calling maybe
we're calling them but is that calling
um the human trafficking home to say did
so and so show up that's not ensuring
the safety of these kids
and we've heard about families that want
to send
um young children over here because
they're unsafe at home but border patrol
agents found an infant in a field alone
covered in fire ants
Nearly Dead
and they were able to save that young
baby boy's life
many do not make it across the border
adults and children
when I visited Uvalde I heard of
high-speed chases that occur three and
four times a week shutting down the
schools
I've heard that the ER is full of women
the OB units are full of women having
babies and border patrol agents must
stay there while those women are in
labor
what border patrol agents have described
to me is like a war zone
and that's certainly not far from what I
witnessed in Eagle Pass Texas we visited
a homeowner where he sees 500 to a
thousand Crossings across the river
every day his property four acres of his
property uh looked like a landfill
he and others expressed to me that if
title for when title 42 expires they
expect a four-fold increase in border
crossings every day
it is a humanitarian crisis
now we've heard from our friends across
the aisle that this has no chance of
being enacted into law
I think there's a chance of it being
enacted into law
the Democrats just have to vote for this
bill
and they have they need to join us
there can't be a head in the sand
approach On the Border securing the
border is the first step in
comprehensive immigration reform
now I also heard some comments about
um
it's if show me a 30-foot wall I will
show you a 35 foot ladder
but I can tell you it's faster to cross
an unimpeded border than it is to climb
a 30-foot fence
border patrol agents would tell you that
this is not just build a wall
the wall is a deterrent
it just it can slow them down
they also need technology they also need
personnel
they told me as part of the Trump
Administration that all of that was
planned
wall technology personnel
and that once the administration took
over the Biden Administration took over
all of that was out the window
and we are in a crisis
so I'm asking I'm encouraging I think
that if anyone saw what I saw at the
border
they would say this can't continue
we must secure the Border and we must
joined together to do that so I would
encourage our friends across the aisle
to come together and join us in securing
the Border
Indiana has a tracker for opioid and
Fentanyl related overdose deaths in our
state 220 of my constituents in the
Ninth District have died from drug
related overdose deaths in LA in the
last year alone
that's 220 Sons daughters mothers
fathers family members even one is too
many and many of those deaths are a
direct result of the influx of drugs
like fentanyl from across our unchecked
Southern border chairman green I
appreciate your comments about how we
don't know how much fentanyl is crossing
the border illicitly I can tell you that
border patrol agents told me when I
visited uh Uvalde that there are as many
as 85 children are being held at one
point in Mexico for one day to push them
all across at once as a distraction for
border patrol agents so they can the
cartels can get all the other illicit
activity through unimpeded
we've all heard stories but seeing it in
person
it's caused needless pain and suffering
for Americans it certainly caused
needless pain and suffering for those in
South Texas I wonder why did it take our
president so long to visit
better yet why hasn't anything been done
to secure the Border
just a few feet from where I was
standing in Eagle Pass Texas in March
and why are the Democrats silent as we
approach the end of title 42 on Thursday
the Department of Homeland Security has
even predicted we could see upwards of
ten thousand border crossings a day
that's ten thousand more uh to add to
the numbers uh the Staggering numbers
that we've already seen it's a national
security issue the president and his
administration have failed they must act
to resolve it on the contrary
Republicans are leading the effort
um and this is evidence of that this
bill
so I have a few questions
um first for chairman Greene
why is it so important uh why was it so
important for the committee to include
reconstruction of the border wall in the
bill and what benefit does that give to
our national security
so the issue of the border wall and
thanks for the question
it's pretty simple walls work they do
work uh CBP actually itself published an
article on it
um
when the when the wall was built in Yuma
there was an 87 percent decrease in
illegal crossings from FY 19 to FY 20.
there is others
October 2020 CBP press release and I
quote the results speak for themselves a
legal drug border crossings and human
smuggling activities have decreased in
areas where barriers are deployed the
border wall is forcing drug smugglers to
where we are best prepared to catch them
our ports of Entry the walls do work
despite
arguments made to the contrary and there
was a study done on the San Diego wall
when it was uh implemented that showed a
98 decrease in illegal border crossing
so the substantially
um and I'll just speak as a military guy
who used to I mean we use walls to to
canalize people which means to make them
all move to a certain area where you can
better control them uh you can better
assist them
uh they work and there clearly it's I
agree with uh uh Chief Ortiz when he
said that we're not going to build a
wall from sea to shining see it's not
necessary but there are areas where it
would be beneficial when asked under
oath in front of our committee just
recently the chief of the border patrol
currently working for the Secretary of
uh you know secretary mayorkas said that
he disagreed with President Biden's
immediate stop of border wall
construction I think that says it all
thank you
um
one of the things that that I heard when
I was in Uvalde is that the illicit
activity is totaling three and a half
million dollars a week in um drug
trafficking uh human trafficking organ
trafficking and other things can you
elaborate on the improvements of the
technology that are included in this
bill and how that assists DHS in
apprehending human and drug traffickers
and Smugglers so in this bill we have a
technology plan that we're asking for
from the Department where they will go
and build out their basically their
technology requests uh and and it also
requires that they create a plan that
extends beyond the current needs so that
they're forecasting how they'll do
Acquisitions
etc for any new technology that's
developed or implemented or or evolves
over the next several years so the the
bill specifically says that they have to
create a plan come back to us with that
plan and then we'll execute uh you know
Appropriations Etc to get that done
thank you Mr McClintock regarding the
crisis of the unaccompanied children at
our Southwest border we've heard some of
this from Dr Burgess but isn't it true
that the Obama Biden Administration
sought to have the authority to quickly
screen and return children back home yes
they did and by the way we do that any
child that comes to us through Canada or
Mexico
um uh there's a resident of those
countries we get them safely home that's
what you do if a little wave showed up
on your doorstep you wouldn't take them
10 Doors Down to the Sweatshop or Worse
you'd you'd get them safely home and
this bill simply uh says that we're
going to try to get every child safely
home because again you know you want to
stop this this is trafficking the
cartels are doing the trafficking they
are making thousands and thousands of
dollars on every child they bring into
this country through this this uh
horrific and and dangerous process
um uh I've asked the border patrol how
do we stop this send them home the
cartels don't give refunds the moment
one of these children is returned to
their home the trafficking stops because
their business will dry up and for some
reason we can't get our colleagues to
understand this fundamental point and
isn't that the same Authority that we're
providing in hr2 yes yes
regarding the changes to Asylum law
um isn't it true that those with
legitimate Asylum Claims can have their
cases heard faster years faster than
they would under the career of course
the courts are completely gutted now
with with the phony Asylum claims of why
are they making the phony Asylum claims
because they work you make a phony
Asylum claim uh it's very simple you get
uh instant admission to the United
States you get a free ticket anywhere
you want to go you get lots of free
stuff including cash uh you get
indefinite residency permission you get
indefinitely work authorization uh and
years from now when they finally get
around to your case and your order
deported you can be very confident
you're not going to be deported under
this Administration we've got 1.2
million deportation orders that are
simply going unenforced they've been
through the process they've been ordered
deported and and the administration
simply refuses to enforce those
deportations that's why they're coming
now this bill says by the way this bill
says if you want to make an asylum claim
a claim you may
uh and it will be processed but we're
going to enforce the existing law this
is not a new law the existing law that
says that during dependency of your of
of of your your claim of uh you must be
detained uh as as Justice Alito said in
his shall be detained means shall be
detained the problem is this
Administration refuses to do so so what
we're saying is if you're not going to
be detained here in the United States
you're free to return to Mexico you're
free to uh seek a residency in in any uh
safe Third Country uh that we have an
agreement with uh but you're not going
to be admitted into the country suddenly
all of the incentives to make phony
claims disappear and now you've got room
for the legitimate claims to be heard in
a timely manner thank you
yes just for a minute I mean it's just
object the administration is not
supporting people
for dealing with the deportation of a
gentleman in my district there there are
1.2 Ms gallon there are 1.2 million
deportation orders that this
Administration is not enforcing
so big well this Administration this
this President on his on his first day
in office ordered ice not to enforce
deportations you can't get any more
abrasion than that I will also just add
that
um you know my my husband has been a
prosecutor for 16 years he's now a judge
and uh during the Obama Administration
could not get uh people that committed
violent crimes
um and uh sex crimes deported they are
in U.S prisons
um well thank you I I appreciate it
Republicans once again are leading uh
with the strongest um border security
bill that we've seen in years I hope
that our Democrat colleagues will
finally join us in securing the Border
as I said this is the first step in
comprehensive immigration reform uh we
must secure the border for all the
reasons that we've discussed uh today
and I'm I'm proud to support this this
bill with that I yield back to Mr Norman
thank you
hmm
sure thank you gentlelady a gentleman
from South Carolina is recognized
thank you I appreciate the panelists
coming in
um
you know the sad part about all this
that we're seeing play out
uh and Congressman McClintock you
mentioned it you're only as good as
if you enforce it
now everybody's up in our arms about
title 42 ending
they haven't since this Administration
took office they have been enforcing It
Anyway the numbers show that
I've been to the Border like I think
most of y'all it is sickening to see
what's happening
uh it's sickening to see uh the children
that are getting raped it's sickening to
see the fentanyl that came into South
Carolina and I would add we're all
border states now that could have killed
half the state of South Carolina which
is 2.4 million people
we've got a total population of 5.2 it's
sickening to see uh the farmers we met
with we went to the Border fences are
being cut walls are being built
to protect themselves uh to hear the
farmer plead with us please do something
it's sickening to see law enforcement
who we met with this week who don't know
who in the world they're stopping
when illegals are committing crimes in
this country the blood is on the hands
of this Administration for letting this
go and they cannot be said any clear and
to even try to make the argument that
during the Trump Administration the
numbers were not down he was building
900 miles of wall and going to have
designated points of Entry
if walls don't work take the locks off
your house folks
uh take the doors down let everybody in
it doesn't work and Miss McClintock like
you says like you you mentioned uh the
schools that are being overrun now by
the emergency rooms have been overrun
all over this country uh it's sickening
to see that note that that we could
solve it but they're just not going to
do it this Administration is devoid of
any reason they're doing it for one
thing votes and that's uh it was shown
in New York City when they're giving
them licenses it was shown when we were
visiting they were getting on airplanes
where was the coveted vaccine vaccine
card that the illegals had they had none
and so the ngos that are supporting this
is sickening to see this uh and the
issue that all of us face how are you
going to walk this back how do you want
this back in America you can't
unless you line buses up all over the
country and Deport people back and I'm
sick and tired of hearing you know you
have dreamers you have people who are
valid who want to be here that's true
but you verify it and that's what this
Administration is not going to do
um
Mr McClintock if I'm an enforcement
standpoint and I if let's say this bill
passes the house and the senate in a
perfect world uh where's the enforcement
part of this we've got another year of
horror under this Administration
where's the order going to come to
enforce anything that's in this bill
before us
it's a blessing sometimes and a curse
sometimes but in a democracy you get the
government you vote for this is the
government that the people of the United
States voted for if it turns out it's a
government that is not to their liking
they have the opportunity to to rectify
that in the next election I am convinced
this is a deliberate policy it will
continue as long as the people
responsible for it remain in office
and if you want to know why all of this
is happening this is exactly if if you
voted for the for the Democrats this is
exactly what you voted for and if that
surprises you you weren't paying very
close attention because they made it
very clear this was was their intention
so ultimately it will be up to the
American people our job is to provide
the the the laws that can be used uh to
uh to restore the Integrity of our
borders as history screams this warning
at us that countries that either cannot
or will not enforce our borders simply
aren't around very long without in
enforcement of our immigration laws we
have no immigration laws without
immigration laws we have no borders and
if we have no borders we are no longer a
country we are simply a vast
international territory between Canada
and Mexico and that is what the
Democrats I believe have deliberately
imposed on our country and it's going to
be up ultimately the American people to
stop them
and it's sad to say it's probably going
to take another 9 11. that will happen
well that's what worries me the most of
all 1.5 million known godaways now again
those are the people we actually saw
crossing the border illegally we know
nothing about them at all but we do know
this when this Administration
unconditionally surrendered Bagram Air
Force Base uh uh we had the Parlin
military Detention Facility there uh it
was housing more than 5 000 most
dangerous uh terrorists on the planet we
know we're one of those five thousand
women ten days later one of those 5 000
went to Abigail at uh Kabul Airport and
detonated a bomb that killed 13 U.S
Marines we don't know where the other
five thousand are we do know we've been
able to intercept 100 or so known
terrorists at the border we don't know
how many are among the 1.5 million
godaways I am afraid there will come a
day when we will suffer a coordinated
attack by terrorists who come through
our Southern border during this this
period uh of time
um and it the other thing I worry about
a lot is we are introducing the the
violent uh cartels into our major cities
how long will it be before we start
seeing the kind of gun battles break out
in our in our American cities that have
become routine in Mexico
well when you it's not a matter of if
it's just when when you let every when
you don't have a border it's not a
matter of if it's just when that's
because then Congressman green y'all
both uh on the National Security front
how dangerous is what what this
Administration is doing has been doing
where where uh
how do you put a figure on what is most
likely going to uh
affect this country for a long time how
many more 3 000 deaths are we going to
have to take before we finally wake up
and
and this is not a Democrat or Republican
issue this is an American issue yeah and
thanks for the question I was a
counter-terrorism federal prosecutor in
Texas with a border I've been dealing
with this issue for
well over 20 years and chairman of
Homeland but when you have five million
encounters and five million people
potentially in this country were that
have no legal status
where they're they're manipulated with
trafficking
um with the women get traffic the the
men go to gangs
um Mr McClintock mentioned the numbers
on potential terrorists when I chaired
Homeland that was the stat I asked every
every week I have my my classified
briefings how many special interest
aliens got in how many on the terror
watch list because that was that was the
number that uh was the biggest threat
biggest threat it has a financial toll
that's beyond belief
uh but then the fentanyls the human toll
on that a hundred thousand people dead
that's more than Vietnam over 20 years
a hundred thousand people and that
number's climbing it's coming in from
China going through Mexico and it's
going all throughout the United States
when you don't have any accountability
and you have a wide open board you don't
know who's coming in
you're really asking for it not to
mention the crime rate
which we're going to see soar
as a result of this because they're not
going to have illegal status so what do
you do living in the shadows
I mean it's it's very it's not it's very
common sense as you're pointing out
the dangers this this is it such a
threat to the United States not only
from a criminal standpoint but a
national security standpoint and a drug
standpoint and if we don't get control
over this soon
I'm afraid it'll be hard to turn back
well we've got a congressman green sure
sure I you know the the 1.5 million got
away is the known number uh you can add
on to that what uh Chief Ortiz believes
is another 20 where they get our hits at
the
um fiber optics in the ground where they
know people are coming across but
they're not getting their eyes on so
they don't count those as gotaways
they're they actually have another term
for it but he thinks that number is
another 20 so another 300 so 1.8 million
and it's interesting right now if you
turn yourself into Customs and Border
Patrol you're going to get released into
the country they're not deporting
they're not they've allowed the return
agreements to expire with the other
countries I mean you're good so if
you're intentionally avoiding CBP it
begs the question you know what's the
intent we talked about the videos
earlier of the drug you know packs of
fentanyl coming in Etc
what concerns me more is we when we talk
to the sector Chiefs uh and we're
Gathering testimony from them now
we have in for example the Del Rio
sector 25 to 35 Chinese Nationals
age 25 to 35 with known associations to
the pla being released into the country
every day now that's in one sector a day
you think about the Chinese Bible Loom
that ever pretty much everybody in the
country was frustrated that that was
allowed to Traverse the country when we
get to the bottom of the numbers of
people
with affiliations with the pla coming
into the United States and just being
released into the country we're going to
get to the bottom of it that's an
upcoming uh planned hearing because of a
whistleblower that came to us
I think I think people are going to
really be shocked at what's really
happening at our Southern border but uh
it's Our intention to shine a light on
that over the coming months
well I'll just close with this
um
again to try to walk this back I don't
know how you do it
with what's going on now with five
million that we think
but more or less before this
Administration is over with uh we'll
have 12 to 15 million it's like the
airline pilot told me off record he said
we're struggling we can't catch
everybody that's that is most likely
going to cause another 911. and then
what what will this What will what will
be our reaction
and I think this is a good bill it's got
some enforcement issues as as I
mentioned
um it's got Mr chairman Cole I know what
the 20 of us did back in January was to
get a 72-hour rule where we get get
amendments and in place early this
violates that
and that's a that's a problem going
forward a huge problem because that's
not the process that we I think is fair
to everybody again it's not a Democrat
or Republican it's an American
democracy that the way it ought to work
but thank each one of you for the time
I'm not going to be the dead horse
anymore
um and Miss chairman I yield back I
appreciate that
um a couple of things we're getting
ready to recess so number one we have
three votes on the floor uh I would
advise the witnesses none of your
excused yet your testimony is still here
so immediately after the third vote we'd
request that you return back up here
obviously same thing to the member
thank you
foreign